I had to take 20 hits because at the swap scenes!
He gets a free win!
Please.
Please!
Leave me alone!
I'm playing quick play because I don't want to lose Shinri.
I didn't want to lose Shinri before this stream.
I'm blocked!
Goodbye!
I won a quick play game.
Let's go!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Yes, I am now Shinri!
Alright.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the Yoshi.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I didn't forget.
I got to Shinri!
I'm rigged up!
I'm like two rings...
Oh, Shinryu.
Shinri, Shinryu, it's the same.
Okay, I'm going into the main menu now.
I didn't forget.
Hey, hey, hey.
Not feeling good today?
I feel so good.
I'm not going to throw up.
You're ready to go.
Yeah, totally.
I didn't already.
Did you throw up from the pressure already?
No, no, no.
How are you feeling pressured?
You literally got coached, Matt!
You actually got coached this time!
I'm always pressured.
It's Sunday!
You rise again on Sunday!
I'm not!
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready for you.
Where's Slime?
The reason I was going to come here earlier and warm up, but I was just watching the Melee Restream with Slime the whole morning.
What?!
Yeah, I was watching Gommel too.
I can't believe it.
You guys are not serious.
Don't worry, I was practicing.
Okay, that's okay.
Me, Slime, or Coney just needs to lose one so we can force BrawlPro to play a game.
Why do you want to force that?
Why are we forcing it?
Because somebody didn't take it seriously.
Because you gotta earn it!
You gotta earn it!
Coach!
Yeah, you gotta earn it!
You fucking watched a different stream instead of help coaching us?
You're gonna slide off me, Doki, and Slime?
Yeah!
You gonna mooch off of us?
I'm gonna make sure Gommel hits every shot.
I'm just gonna throw up, bro.
You're just gonna...
On purpose.
Mine will be... Oh, such a sad accident.
I'm gonna blow all the funny moves.
Key charge in front of them.
Dude, I was playing Jack in Quick Play yesterday.
That character is so fucking funny.
He just... He has so many stupid moves that you would never do.
I love him.
Yeah, he's goofy.
Maybe that could be your number two.
I think I would like him more than Paul.
I played a little bit of Paul, and he's good.
But I think you have to be good at the game.
I think I could just do dumb funny shit with Jack.
You know?
And that'd be good.
I wish there were hero bans in Tekken.
Hero bans?
God.
Got that over-aught Gringotts.
I know that's you.
Could you imagine the level of play in this tournament if there were...
It would all just be like one-twos.
People would just be hitting one-twos over and over.
Okay.
See?
Oh, wait.
What?
While standing.
There you go.
And then remember, Goomy's gonna mash after too.
So you gotta forward two-one after.
Remember?
Okay.
I mashed it!
Remember your forward two-one after?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your two-elbow?
Because she'll mash after you punish her.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Yes.
Nice.
Just like that.
And from a distance.
Okay.
It's okay.
That's why we're here.
No!
Oh, no.
Okay.
No!
See, this is why I knew this before our game.
She's grunting like she's getting hit in real life.
Yeah.
Oh, come on!
How come I couldn't get that?
There you go.
Fucking warm up right here.
Yeah.
See?
I'm warming up the fingers.
Okay.
This is not fair.
All right.
And then she also does that a lot.
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
That's right!
Okay.
That's not right.
And then she'll do it again after me.
No.
They're not gonna show me every mash.
Not?
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's gonna be one side of the bracket.
I don't know.
I'll have to chat, I guess.
Oh.
Maybe while setting four after you duck it and then back three.
Okay.
Or, yeah, just while setting four and then back three.
All right.
Do you know while setting four the one you're doing to punish this one?
Yeah.
When you duck, just do it again.
Okay.
Or that.
I mean, you can do that if you want to if you're up for it.
That.
Okay.
Diane huh!
Zero.
What?!
It mashed the...
Sometimes, it doesn't register when I mash.
Okay, do it fire.
Yeah!
Hell, yeah.
Hell, yeah!
Yeah!
That's what's important.
Oh!
And remember that step, too.
That's a good way to make space.
Yeah.
Yeah!
See, I can learn!
Do it again, do it again.
The Jaguar step and then it's back 3 plus 4.
Yeah, and that's what sets up for your running knee.
Gumi will duck a lot when you're running up on her, so you gotta do that knee into the shoulder.
Okay.
Into your L3 or whatever that... yeah, that one.
Just hold forward and just mash that out.
Yeah!
I'm learning!
Wait, why are you BMing me?
Did you two...
Wait, no, no way!
I would never... I would never do that to the coach.
I would never.
Yeah, exactly.
Wait, what?
How come I can't do that?
Okay.
How did you get yours over mine?
You have to just... right when you block, you don't even have to block and just yeah, just mash once more.
I smashed it!
Yeah.
It's an OS.
I MASHED IT!
THERE'S NO WAY!
It's only on block that you can mash it though.
Yes, yes.
Gumi will mash after so you can forward to 1-er right away.
Boom, boom.
Yeah, she's gonna get hit by that.
And then remember after that, then you can run up into all your bullshit.
And yeah, your heat stuff, everything.
Okay.
No, come on!
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
What's up Matt?
Are they starting?
Should be starting.
Oh, they didn't.
Yeah.
I'm just saying because we gotta figure out where we're gonna fight.
Check the engines.
Chill dude again.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no!
I got confused.
Why are you streaming Tekken and not Tekken 8?
Chill dude again.
I'm doing Tekken 1?
Yeah, you're streaming Tekken.
No caps, just Tekken.
Okay.
I got it.
Team, we might be cooked.
What do you mean?
That's okay.
You know what?
I accept my fate.
I'm just kidding dude.
I'm just joking.
I'm trying my best.
You gotta mix it up!
You gotta mix it up because now I'm thinking about the spin!
You can't just keep going.
You can't just keep doing the same thing!
See, now I can block this now!
Dude, you're doing fine.
You gotta mix it up!
See, now I can...
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay.
No!
No.
I forgot this.
Oh no, now I don't feel that confident anymore.
Oh yeah, and remember when we talked about how to wake up off the floor too?
Yeah.
Like one or two instead of... don't roll forward or you can just hold back sometimes.
But generally just hit one or two to get up.
And then when you get up, hold back after.
Okay.
Yeah, just like that.
That's a good way to get up.
Wait, why can't I lock?
Okay.
Yes!
I'm doing it!
Yeah, good job!
No!
I panicked.
Okay.
Okay, Dokie, if you duck this, do the same thing.
The while standing 4.
The same thing after you duck.
Let's see.
My fingers reflexively go to 3.
I see.
Yeah, but I'll go 4.
I'll try 4 again.
Standing 4.
So, can you do while standing 4 just in a neutral?
Like if you crouch and like that?
Yeah.
That, yeah.
That's... after we duck, that's what... you basically let go, crouch and you hit 4 basically.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then after that, you can do back 3.
If you hop kick after it, sometimes it's not gonna work.
Okay.
And then you can back 3 there.
And do your tornado.
Oh, no!
Fuck!
I... I...
Honestly, even... yeah, yeah.
Even if you don't get the full punish, as long as you're not getting hit by that, it's still...
Yeah.
...still pretty good.
Okay.
Fuck!
Bye.
And she'll always do it again, remember?
Yeah.
Every time.
So, block after she heat engages and then duck.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can even back 3 off of standing 4 too even if you get that kick.
Okay.
Or, yeah.
You could do that too.
Okay.
You could back 3 by itself.
Yeah.
And then you do the jaguar bomb, the ender.
There you go.
Fuck it.
Fuck.
Okay.
Yeah.
And you can take your time with the ender.
You don't have to, you know.
Yes.
Yes!
Yeah!
Oh god!
No!
Here we go.
And then remember, in this range right here, you have a good whiff punish that's a forward 2-1.
You see them whiffing?
Yeah, it's a good move in the mid-range at this level.
And then again, she's gonna start doing this from afar.
Okay, okay.
My mind didn't process it.
Okay, I'm ready.
There's three things.
Yeah, hopkick.
Hopkick before you think you have to.
Okay.
It's not easy.
Fuck this, I'm doing this.
This is easier.
And then you can do the two kicks after and then back three, remember?
Okay, try it.
It's easier.
That's easier!
Yeah.
What?!
Okay, whatever.
Well, that didn't work.
What?!
Yeah, that move sucks.
I'm not gonna lie.
I hate this move so much!
You're doing good against it.
Yes.
Oh, are you on your new PC now?
We didn't lag at all.
Um...
I fixed it.
Wait, what?
IT Dosey?
I fixed it.
Oh, yeah.
And remember, you got the back three 1 plus 2.
Pretend it's like a string and hit that.
Back three 1 plus 2, remember?
Okay, back three 1 plus 2.
Okay.
The 1 plus 2 button.
Pretend it's a string and it should work or match it up.
Oh, no, that's not it.
You know that back three and it leads into the leg drop, remember?
Yeah.
Try that.
Oh!
Okay.
Ah!
No!
You can just hold 1 plus 2 afterwards.
Try that, Dokie, if you back three 1 plus 2 and you just hold it after.
Back three...
Oh, maybe it's easy.
Okay.
Yeah, what's your...
Okay, they're starting now.
Okay, there you go.
And the shoulder after, remember?
Yeah.
Yeah, that thing.
It's gonna destroy people.
I just can't get it the timing correctly.
Okay, now put me on the other side.
Put me on the other side, please.
Thank you.
Oh.
Alright.
Are they starting the matches now?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna watch...
Who are we watching?
Um, we're gonna watch the main channel.
Who is playing on the main channel?
The Stay Jam stream.
You can watch that.
I'm gonna do warm-up games with my other monitor.
I guess I'll pull up the matches for my stream.
Alright.
Who do...
I don't know.
Who do we watch, guys?
While I practice too.
It sucks because no one fucking plays Yoshi.
I literally...
Every time I rank when I find a Yoshi player, I just be like, please fight me.
Stream's like, Gumi, she's too low elo to fight me.
I'm sorry.
Is that mean?
Like in the rank.
I can't fucking get into rank matches.
Unless she does like...
I do plus...
I do minus plus two.
And I'm...
Senior...
Right now.
So like I play against Vanquisher and...
Which one is it?
I like...
Because I have a...
I strictly do like only within two of my ranks.
And I don't think she's within two of my ranks at the moment.
It's not toxic!
I can't...
Literally can't stream stay.
Rank is Gumi.
She's on Destroyer.
Okay.
Oh, she's playing now.
All right, let's see.
It's not toxic!
I literally can't stream snipe her in rank.
I'm watching it right now.
I'm watching how...
Oh my gosh.
Amore's being the shit out of Gumi.
Like what is she doing?
Cause like...
I always...
The only thing that she fucks me up on is the spin.
That's literally it.
It's the fucking spin.
Yeah, you gotta play one of these two.
Yeah, I'm surprised.
Like what is Amore doing?
That's different from what I was doing.
Oh, she knows combos.
That's what's different.
She actually knows combos.
Damn!
Oh my God.
My God, why can't I do that?
Wait.
She's not doing anything.
Is she doing a spin?
Wait, what?
She is.
Wait, Amore's going crazy.
Oh my God.
She actually knows combos.
Dude, did you see that combo she did?
Kony doesn't even do that one.
What the fuck?
She knows combos.
That's fucking crazy.
How is that possible?
Hahaha!
Round one.
Fight.
In.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what?
I wish I know combos.
I know this though.
Yeah!
That's all I need to know.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe not.
I'm so sorry.
That's not all I need to know.
You're right.
Oh my God.
Maybe not.
Maybe I need to know more of that.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh wait, what?
Okay.
I'm surprised.
Oh my God.
He low parries that.
It's like he knows.
Hahaha.
He's the champ.
Round two.
Fight.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's not fair.
How do all these players know combos?
Like, how do you stay in tenure knowing all these combos when I can abuse certain stuff to Shinryu?
Hahaha.
All I'm saying is like, I don't know.
If I don't know combos and I can get to this rank in one week, maybe these players are...
Hahaha.
Oh yeah, yesterday in rank, I bumped into a... in rank, I had to fight a purple.
And they were like a TTV-er.
So then I looked at their TTV, and I was like...
And then I looked at their VODs, and it took them like one month of playing.
Because they were like hard stuck red for like so long.
And then they recently like yesterday got to purple.
And it took them like a month straight of playing Tekken to get there.
And I'm like, bro, what?
It took me one week to get to red.
I feel like if I commit another week, maybe I'll learn how to get to...
Because they were... I was like looking at their VODs, and I was like, oh shit, they're...
They're... I was just like...
I was like, they've been playing rank every day for a month straight from red to purple.
Playing... Bro, that guy was a king player!
You can't say that!
Don't you definitely stay aggressive against her?
That guy was a king player, so I was like watching.
Because I was like, oh hey, a fellow king.
Who's in purple?
Let me see your fucking thing.
Getting to purple is the one Tekken...
He's playing king wrong.
Bro, I fucking hate fighting all the...
Okay, this one's new.
Okay.
I swear, every time I see an arena player, I'm just like, I'm done.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of playing against all the arenas!
Thank god this is quick play.
I really don't want to play rank right now.
I grinded rank a lot yesterday and I'm tired.
That's good!
I'm so happy I can play someone else that's...
I'm tired of playing against all the fucking arenas and paws and fucking dragon elves and laws.
Like, I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
And Alyssa's too.
I want to play new characters.
I'm fine with playing against Claudio if he's someone new.
I'm... God, get away from me!
I'm streaming!
Okay.
So glad I played against him.
Yeah, because like, his moves aren't fucking bullshit.
Like, I can actually get out of the moves later.
I say... Like, look, see, I can actually get up.
When I play against Reyna, I like fucking...
Like, just not play for like 20 minutes.
Say he's the king player, to be fair.
Say he's the king player.
Look, I'm just done.
Yeah!
Now we're at the other wall!
No, my other wall!
Yeah!
Timed correctly!
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Oh, no!
No!
Please!
Leave me alone!
No!
Take me back to the other side!
I don't like being on this side!
They don't know I can't play... I literally cannot play on this side.
Like, it's actually so bad.
If they put me on this side, I'm helpless.
I'm like a sheep.
They don't know.
They don't know on this side I'm scared.
The right side is where... where things go down.
I just don't know how to... Like, okay, like my brain can't fucking reverse the input.
That's the thing.
I have to reverse the input and I don't know how to do that.
Get ready for the next battle!
I don't know how to reverse inputs.
Why say that before...
Cause then they have to take me to the other side!
They gotta figure out how to put me on the other side!
They gotta figure it out first how to put me there.
Cause it's usually I put myself there.
That's the thing.
I put myself out on the other side.
It's usually not like... Usually not the enemy team that does it.
It's me.
Oh my god, please.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, I saw Goomy at one.
Yo, Matt.
Yeah, what's up, dude?
Um, are you watching?
Not really.
What's going on?
It's kinda crazy.
What?
What happened?
Fight!
I don't know.
These two girls just now were fucking insane.
Oh, Goomy versus Amore?
I have no way of the monitor.
Yeah.
Oh, please!
Please!
Leave me alone!
Just a helpless King player!
I don't know what I'm doing!
This is my first fighting game!
You've been playing fighting games your whole fucking life!
I'm just a silly jaguar!
Oh, fuck.
I missed it.
I'm streaming!
Leave me alone!
How do you know that?
You can tell.
Because he knows combos.
The most...
New fighting players don't know what...
People who never play fighting games barely register combos.
We just fucking play... We just press the buttons that we know works.
Wheeee!
Just learn combos.
No, that's just you?
No.
All I'm saying is if you know combos and you're still in Shinri, then like you've been a fighting player for so long.
Because like...
Because you just do the...
You just listen to what...
That all the guides tell you to.
You know what I mean?
You like... You don't come up with your own strategies to climb the ranks.
You like follow...
What the sheep... You're like a sheep.
So you follow what they tell you to do because it's what's right.
It's what's always been.
But like those who are new to fighting games...
They like see and don't like have like...
Don't have like background in fighting games.
We basically...
We come up with our own strategies that we see that works and then abuse it until it stops working.
And then we have to come up with our new...
With new strategies.
But people with fighting game experience...
They just come in doing the same combos over and over and over again.
And like doing the like...
The foundation stuff.
Because they're taught from fighting game experience that that is how to do.
Like that is like what you have to do to climb.
And if I can just abuse simple buttons...
And just not knowing what the fuck I'm doing and get to this elo...
That means I'm not from this...
I'm not from this community.
Okay.
No!
Nice.
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
Oh shit.
Goodbye to me.
Oh boy!
Oh please!
I haven't registered pattern yet.
You can get stuck playing a certain...
You can get stuck?
Yeah but the thing is...
I just need to learn a new...
New cheese.
That's it.
Every time I learn a new cheese like I climb.
Like and I just need to learn a new cheese.
In this elo.
It just works!
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Oh.
Whoops.
Stop.
Oh fuck!
He didn't stop.
Why didn't you stop?
I don't understand.
Oh!
Stop!
Fight.
Oh.
Nice.
Got that.
Boom!
Okay.
Yeah!
Stop!
It's true.
I just need to...
Whoa!
But does that stop from there?
No!
Wait what?
How?
Whoa!
Yeah!
Get away!
Go away!
Whoa!
He ducked!
Cat duck forever!
Bam!
Because I play King!
That's fucking right!
Stay on the ground!
Nobody likes you!
Not even your mom.
Not get ally kicked to death.
I don't even earn elo for that.
I tried because I hate you.
There.
Okay guys, look at... look at like... we were checking our play data.
Look at my defense guys.
Wait, where is it?
Performance stats.
Look at my...
It's so bad.
We were comparing our D's... our stats... our stats to people.
And it's so bad.
I don't fucking...
How the fuck do people... How the fuck do people let me get away with this?
How do people let me climb to this?
Look, this is the Tekken 8 community's fault for putting me... for letting me climb this high.
Exactly.
Why do I need defense if... if I could just kill them?
You have been enabled.
Look at that.
It's just that easy.
Woooo!
Yeah, never need to learn throw techs if I'm doing the throwing.
That is so true.
That is so fucking true.
I don't know any throws... like I don't know how to do any tech stuff.
All I do is... grapple.
Crap.
Only cowards.
Yeah, accept your throws.
Accept your fate.
You know what you're getting into.
Just lie back and think of Paris.
While I throw you to the fucking ground.
Exactly.
Take the throw!
Oh shit.
Sir.
Please.
All I know, I don't know how to D.
Take this.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
And this!
Oh shit!
Okay, you actually... you don't block.
Okay, so...
Okay, so that's good to know.
That's good to know you don't duck.
Like, I like that.
That's the king's dream right there.
Take my throw!
Yeah!
And again!
Oh wait, sorry.
Oh shit, sorry.
He doesn't want me to throw him.
I don't know why.
Why won't you want me to fucking throw you?
People fucking line up for that.
Oh my god, he's staying on the ground now.
It's like...
A lifetime opportunity.
Yay.
Stay on the ground.
Why is she getting away with it?
That's what I'm saying.
A lot of these fighting players in this elo, they have like...
They just follow what the sheep tell them to do.
And because of that, they don't know what to do when someone does something different.
As in five alley kicks in a row.
It's just so fucked up.
They're just... they're so confused.
They're like, what?
How is she letting you get away with this?
You just don't know.
They're so confused when people do that.
Because it's so unorthodox.
So I just like abuse the stuff that they don't... are not used to.
Oh, he does that same move over and over again.
Yeah, let me... let me breathe.
Let me breathe.
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you fucking counted that?
That's not fair!
Oh, you counted that too.
That's fine.
Oh shit, it's not fine?
Question?
Whoa!
That's my move.
Okay.
He does that all the time.
Nice.
And then I do that.
And then I rush in!
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm not even...
There you go.
See that?
You like that little spin?
I did... oh shit.
Whoops.
Oh, I still have this.
I didn't even realize I still have my heat.
Oh, no.
No!
I pressed the wrong button!
Oh, it's fine.
He pressed the wrong button too.
Oh my god!
That's so fucked up!
It would be a shame if he died like this.
Goodbye.
Fucking go back to yellow rank.
And you don't get a rematch.
Get outplayed.
Yay!
Yippee!
Okay.
Not toxic at all.
Oh my god.
A fellow King player.
Show me.
This is going to be a King player to actually know his combos.
Oh my god!
He actually knows how to do that!
Oh, he jumped.
I should have...
I need to know how...
Remember to...
Oh my god, he did that thing!
My coach keeps telling me to do!
My god!
That's fucking right!
You should learn how to do that too!
Oh shit.
Never mind.
I'm a king player.
I don't know how to tech.
I don't know how to tech that.
Oh, that sidestep.
He fucking knows.
It's not fair.
You're also a king.
You know what I want to do.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's not right.
He threw me away.
Oh my god.
He's doing all the king stuff I would do!
Back to me!
Who is he?
He's in my mind!
What the fuck!
He's actually in my mind!
Oh my god!
He's fucking rock, paper, scissoring me correctly!
That's actually crazy!
See, this is a king player that knows his shit.
But yet, he's still in Vanquisher, so that's embarrassing.
You clearly know what you're doing!
How are you in this elo?
You're losing it.
I don't know how he's in this... in Vanquisher.
If he can do all that and he's still stuck in Vanquisher...
Bad matchup exists, Doki.
If bad matchup exists, how would they let me into this elo?
I cannot get all good matchups for this.
That's all I'm saying.
That's all I'm saying, guys.
Boop.
I lost, therefore you should be embarrassed.
If you could do all that and you're still here?
You're still in Vanquisher?
That's probably like his second...
Why would you create smurf accounts for this?
Don't you need to pay for it?
Don't you need to buy more tech in the...
Oh, I guess if you play on console, you don't have to.
That makes sense.
If you play on console, you don't have to create new smurf accounts.
I was just thinking like, that's crazy.
To still win.
That's true.
His power level was like 145.
He must have been like a god or something in his main character.
And this was just his side project.
Boop.
Okay.
I know like this move.
And then...
Boop.
I try to do this correctly.
But I always fuck it up.
Because it's like...
There's no scenario where people would let me do that.
I don't...
I don't know when I can do this.
It's not fair.
Boom.
Like this is a...
Oh, and then I can do this.
Yeah.
Remember your training?
I am.
I'm trying my best.
I'm scared.
I haven't been nervous at all throughout this event until now.
This is where I've never been so nervous before.
I'm nervous.
Yeah.
No, because now it matters.
Before it didn't really matter.
Now it matters.
Remember to block with what?
My 30 fucking block?
Watch this.
Oh, he blocked too.
It was cool for a second though.
Not gonna lie, it was pretty cool when I did make it work though.
Oh God.
Oh.
Oh my God.
I don't know his fucking moveset.
Get over here.
Oh shit.
Let me back on the other side.
Hahahaha.
Fight.
Oh.
Oh no!
Oh no, he punished me!
No!
Let me back up!
Okay.
Bye.
I think he blocks that.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I'm pretty sure he would like fucking...
That's right!
Alley kick!
Oh!
I'm sorry!
It didn't mean to alley kick you 20 times!
But what if I do it again?
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
Oh my god, please leave me alone.
Wait, what?
I don't slam that?
Oh.
Oh, he blocks it.
Oh, I should have RROC'd him or RDK'd him.
Does he block?
What?!
How is he so fast?!
Someone check this man's system!
Make him pee in the cup!
I'm not mashing.
I have a strategic way of doing my buttons.
Ooh!
Mashing can't get me down.
This!
Oh.
Oh, I can't remember if he's faster than me always.
He's always faster than me.
So it sucks.
Uuugh!
No!
I fucked it up!
Ah!
I fucked that up too!
There you go.
I didn't fuck this up.
Yay!
Goodbye.
Wait, he's Keeshan?!
You fucking trash.
If you can be Keeshan, I can be Keeshan too.
That guy was fucking blue.
Imagine losing.
Oh my god.
I beat all fucking blue.
Embarrassing.
You should uninstall the game, bro.
If your whole life was Tekken 8 and you let that happen to you, you should uninstall.
My OG can't beat this fucking thing.
All I'm saying...
I don't know.
Yeah, beat up blue.
Stop making me feel cool.
I should rename my name.
Doh King uninstalled now.
Oh no.
Oh, this is where I get absolutely destroyed by the better King player.
Yeah, I have a feeling he knew about our...
He would know about the fucking...
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
He's an actual King player!
Boop.
He should uninstall Tekken now.
Oh, he did that thing.
I can do that too.
Oh, I want to do that.
Oh, see, I can mirror you.
That was an accident.
But, oh my god, I Tekked it.
How?
Good question.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
I Tekked it too.
No, I didn't Tek that.
Boop.
Bro, this is like the slowest fucking King player ever.
I swear to god.
I don't get this.
I had a feeling.
Yeah.
I swear, this is the slowest...
I've never seen a King player play this slow.
It's actually crazy how slow of a King player he is.
A King player that thinks?
No way.
That's so fucking rare.
That's actually so rare, man.
He's doing his part.
That's what I'm saying.
I've never fucking seen a King player play this slow before.
Round four.
Fight.
Kings are always so... especially like mirror match kings too.
I guess like... oh wait no.
The Kony matchup was so fucking slow.
Hey!
To be fair, the Kony matchup with... what's his name?
G... uh...
That guy... the other king player that he played?
That was such a slow king matchup.
Oh I won!
I'm the better king.
You play too slow man.
You played... yeah, Jinxen yeah yeah.
You played way too fucking slow.
Yay!
Alright, here we go.
He's almost blue in cat tech shining wizard.
Hey hey hey hey.
I swear these purples and blue rings are fucking easier than the red rings.
I'm gonna say that I'm gonna be absolutely destroyed by these purples.
Thank you for taking me back to the side!
Oh bro, you duck.
I'm gonna say that and now I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed by this guy.
Oh no.
Oh no, leave me alone!
Leave me alone!
Oh, goodbye.
This guy actually knows what he's doing.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry I didn't mean it.
Oh he has four wins, he's actually serious.
Woah, he's actually serious!
Oh, he ducks everything!
But you can't duck this!
Oh god.
Nevermind, you don't need a duck.
You can just beat the shit out of me.
Understandable.
Understandable!
Oh shit, okay.
Understandable.
You hate... you hate tigers.
You hate Jaguars.
You hate... you hate...
You hate...
you hate...
Oh shit.
Oh, goodbye.
I guess I'll go to the moon now.
My people need me.
Oh, he fucking went first!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
This is my sorry punch.
I didn't mean to.
Oh shit.
No.
I'm so sorry.
Please, have mercy.
Okay.
Okay, but will he expect this?
Oh my god!
Who are you?
Does he tech it?
No, he doesn't.
Oh.
No, I've messed up.
Messed it up.
Boom!
JK.
You're right.
Maybe not again.
Maybe not.
Can I please... Can I please get up?
Please, sir.
Please.
Ah!
I deserve that.
I'm sorry for doing the 500 shining wizards.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm so... I'm sorry for all the shining wizards.
I didn't mean to.
I'm so sorry.
It's my bad.
I got cocky.
I got so cocky.
Yeah.
I got humbled.
I mean, there's a reason why my block is at 30.
Okay, I'm gonna block in this one.
Alright.
I'm gonna block on this one.
Oh no.
She's a fast one too.
They always have that ghost.
How do you guys register the fact that I don't block lows?
I guess when you abuse ally kickstats, that's when you know.
Oh.
No, I even fucking... I even tried to block.
I was actually trying to block.
What?
No!
My chat told me to try blocking!
And I always knew that was a mistake!
.
I'll never block again.
My chat was fucking wrong.
.
Oh my god.
I think the issue is that I don't know what move is what.
What is low and what isn't.
That's definitely my issue.
.
Oh,
she doesn't block that though.
.
Does she do it again?
Okay.
.
I'm gonna go get my nipples.
Oh, don't forget everything.
No...
Nice.
I take that one point off the purple.
You are a purple?!
.
That's embarrassing for you.
That's so embarrassing, you should be blocking that.
You're a purple.
.
Okay.
Alright, I'm sorry...
...but you should be blocking that.
.
This is gonna be close, dude.
Oh no.
No, I swear I was at a low.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry for making fun of you, I'm so sorry!
I'm not!
No.
Okay, I'll take those.
Oh!
It's okay, I took two rounds off of fucking purple.
E-rank now.
You should be in my elo.
You should be in my elo for making that too close.
Wow!
That's some fucking bullshit right now.
Yeah, that was way too close.
Yeah, like what?
I actually have 50 hours.
I was looking at how many hours I have.
I have 50-ish hours.
Yeah, I have very weak defense.
The thing is...
A lot of the characters I'm playing... like a lot of the people I'm playing against...
Like, the worst part is like... it's cause they're like such uncommon characters in ranked.
So I barely play against these...
Types of characters.
I think that's like the worst part.
Honestly.
Oh hey, it's Leon.
Cause like I fucking...
I saw like fucking...
My entire time in those 50 hours getting to this elo...
Like all the fucking ranks I...
Like you know from...
From beginner to red...
I saw three Yoshis.
I saw only three Yoshis.
But I saw fucking 200 fucking...
Reinas though.
Like that's the worst part.
Kings were also pretty rare.
I think kings were like...
I think I've seen like...
Maybe like in ranked?
Maybe like...
Uh...
Oh Chester.
Okay.
I'm trying to like think.
I think I've seen like maybe like...
8 king players?
10?
I think 10.
10 king players.
Can you show us up more later on?
Yeah.
I fucking see like...
200 Reinas.
200 Reinas?
Uh...
Who else do I see a lot?
I see a lot of Alyssas too.
Okay.
Oh I fucked up the...
I fucked that up.
I can do it again.
There you go.
I'm like fucked it up.
I got blue 3 back.
I'm warmed up.
The kings and the Yoshis are in the high ranks?
Yeah but it sucks because I don't get a chance to practice.
I still have Azus too.
I'm feeling solid.
I'm feeling like let's just fucking play some video games.
Let's play some video games.
That's it.
Take me back to the other side.
I think we have to do.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh wait you fucking rose?
Oh this guy knows how to play against kings.
This guy knows how to play against kings.
Holy shit.
He actually rose.
Yeah.
Goodbye.
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back chat.
You win.
I'll be right back.
I need to use the bathroom.
You just get to see King and Yoshi.
You're standing there.
Well he almost knows how to play against kings.
Not that.
What was it?
Matching settings.
I'll be back guys.
Alright.
Who's here?
What's up?
We're fighting team NYK.
They had to do a coach match tiebreaker for it.
Yup.
That's a five?
No.
That's crazy.
I was saying you guys watching this right?
I'm back.
I wasn't watching the lily mirror.
He had like crazy scaling.
So it looked like he was going to have to win one more interaction.
And then he got like a wall reset.
And he just blew her up with one move.
I don't know what it was.
Oh he was in heat?
Was it like the mid where she spins in the air and shit?
I don't think so.
It looked like a hole punch.
Someone linked it.
I'm watching it.
I was like okay so the scaling means he can't get the kill here.
And then he like bounced off wall.
I was like oh okay.
It's like 19 I think.
Holy shit he came back like this?
Yeah dude.
Alright do your thing.
Do your thing.
Another hope kick?
Oh no.
No.
Oh what the hell.
Miles got up incorrectly there.
She could have teched but.
That's what that was?
That's not guaranteed.
Let me see it again.
Yeah she could have teched right there.
Okay.
She could have got up.
I think.
This game is still kind of new.
I'm watching on the Sage Jam thing too.
Hits against wall.
That's so weird.
What a weird situation.
Yeah maybe it was guaranteed.
I'm not sure.
Ugh.
You can hold back.
I think if she teched she could have got out of it.
Alright.
Um yeah.
The teams are playing kind of crazy.
I mean I believe in you guys.
So am I.
You are also.
You didn't play with us yesterday.
We had a big session.
I had to fucking clock in for my other job.
What a sad day.
I feel good.
I just got up.
I ranked up again just now.
Everything is fucking nice man.
Big Raijin.
I'm a big Raijin.
Gaming.
It was good.
You kept Josh from practicing though.
That was good.
I actually did.
I know.
Makes sense.
He needed to talk about me.
I mean you also kept me from practicing too.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's not my fault.
You watching my stream is not my fault.
It is your fault.
You guys.
I'm like I gotta go practice.
And you're like practice?
You pay your editor in Tripoli.
Guys what's the move set for it?
So there.
What's the.
Do you guys know the move set for it?
Oh.
I'm Kishin.
Oh no.
Kishin cousin.
It's fine.
Do you even wanna go to Evo?
Who?
Me?
Oh Dokie.
Yeah!
You do?
Okay.
Yeah!
So you guys better win.
Her ass is not going to Evo.
What?
What's the best way?
I don't know how you do it.
Is it like a super chat?
No I want free tickets here.
Yeah.
It's not as good.
Paying your own ticket is not as good as a free ticket.
It's true.
Yeah.
Getting comped from Seijin like it's the fucking Aria.
Mm.
Run me my $40 spare flight.
Run me that shit.
Yeah.
Wait.
Are they actually paying for plane tickets too?
Yeah.
Oh wait.
And hotels?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Win this for me.
Run me my.
We're trapped.
I'm trying to run you your middle seat.
That you deserve.
I deserve this.
I love free stuff.
I'm seeing a lot of discourse on the timeline about throwing chairs.
Dude he...
It was a big throw.
I saw it.
I thought he broke the stage.
Because it was all folded and shit.
But apparently it was like that.
Are we supposed to get on the...
Get on to the room now or no?
Yeah.
They're making a lobby in a second.
I'm gonna go pee.
Alright.
He's like I'm ripping off this shirt if I lose a round.
Our friendship of 8 years will be over for this match.
It was time.
It was a timer and this was it.
Yo he fucked that chair up dude.
Oh my god.
I know dude.
It ran its course.
It's time to end it.
I'm gonna go pee.
On Tekken 8.
Ohhhhh.
I've never felt so nervous before.
I know right.
Like why is this so weird.
Yeah.
Wait Doki you said you've never been this nervous before?
No I've never been this nervous before.
Never in your life?
No one has ever felt that way.
That feel right now.
It's true.
Science needs to study this new feeling.
Yeah this new feeling.
What is this feeling?
Dude this Stajam Slam is pretty stressful yeah.
I mean it's like really good and really bad all together.
Like a rollercoaster.
Hey we'd be feeling much worse if we didn't all have trips.
Obviously we want to get her a trip.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah you guys should feel particularly bad if I don't get a trip.
Yeah.
Stajam's praying for us to win so he doesn't have to double up.
He should give...
I told him he should give like you guys like a budget.
The equivalent to the evo ticket.
A per diem.
Dude wait a minute.
That's kind of... yeah give us 500 for the tables.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I mean how much is it?
How much is like hotel, flight, and ticket?
Add that all together.
Each of us gets a budget.
Yeah we get a per diem.
A lobster dinner every night.
Oh true true true.
That shit ain't sweet dude.
The hotel room has to be an up...
If you guys win we should upgrade our hotel rooms to a suite.
Oh yeah.
I want the heart tub and I want a captain's hat.
The heart tub?
I'll get in the heart tub with the champagne glass.
Oh shit this is the S's ain't enough.
We're in.
Now we're drawing right after this match.
Oh.
I've never been this stressed before.
I know.
Scary.
The first one was really bad too.
It's okay though.
It's fun though.
Yeah and we'll do a little food drive donation drive thing for you.
Okay.
Alright guys.
If I lose this it's because of my coach.
Yeah the box in front of the grocery store will put like canned pumpkin in there.
Yeah.
And I don't get to eat it either.
My coach just didn't coach me hard enough.
It's his fault.
It's not my fault.
He's a king player too.
Yeah I know.
That's like the worst part.
A king player couldn't fucking help me.
Oh he deafened himself.
He doesn't want to.
He did.
His ass is just trying to hear that.
Not today.
100% blaming the coach on this.
Oh my god.
He's just gonna beat me up guys.
Just remember the spinny shit.
I'm gonna try.
You got it.
We believe in you.
Oh shit.
Oh what?
Yes.
Good stuff.
Nice.
I'm coming.
Oh god.
She's doing that thing.
Okay.
Full screen reset.
She's doing that thing.
The spinny thing.
Okay.
I die here.
It's alright.
Just one round.
We lock in.
Good shit.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah but it didn't register.
It's okay.
As long as you're not getting hit.
Oh shit.
She like...
Yes.
Good shit.
Yeah it doesn't matter if you're not punishing.
As long as you're blocking and not taking damage.
Oh my god.
Don't tell me.
Yup.
I love the delay.
Oh my god you're a genius.
Okay.
Good stuff.
Is this it?
Nice.
That's it.
Genius.
Good job.
That was sick.
Yup.
Good shit.
That's a round in the bank.
You probably can hit that every round.
Because Goomy's not respecting it.
Yeah just fucking rip it.
Okay.
Nice.
Good shit.
It's cool.
Oh good check.
I love the dick jab.
Good job.
Oh no.
Good stuff.
Genius.
That's okay.
That's cool.
That was a great round.
I know you lost it.
But it's a good round.
You played that round very well.
Yeah.
Nice.
It's cool.
Oh.
I keep forgetting that.
Helicopter will grab you like that.
I think she hits me.
Oh huge.
And you have heat.
Run up.
Yeah actually that's big.
Okay.
She'll duck after she blocks it.
So you can hit her with the square.
Okay.
Yes!
No.
No I don't think I buffered it though.
Nice try.
I didn't buffer it.
Before yeah.
Very close though.
Yeah.
That was a good match.
You played your game play.
You played it well.
It just you know.
She got a couple more hits.
Yeah.
This is actually so doable.
Ah!
It's all good.
Gamer time.
Gamers only.
From here on out.
Only gamers.
It's all for gamers.
Don't worry.
Good stuff.
Okay.
Unlucky.
Nice!
Good grab.
Oh he wants to press buttons so bad.
This Yoshimitsu.
Nice.
Okay.
Good stuff.
Good weight.
Excellent patience.
I don't hit this.
Oh I do!
Yeah I think you win.
Yeah that's too much damage.
I'm a little lamb.
Hell yeah.
Nice.
Wait no she counter blocked it.
That's fine.
You got the hit.
Nice.
Another one.
Good wizard.
Yes!
Just bring it back.
Oh my god no!
Okay.
Blast him!
Bring it home.
Okay.
You're in your fucking element.
Good stuff!
Oh no.
Great.
Great block.
Patience is great here.
It's fine.
Great block.
Yes!
You're doing so fucking awesome.
Nice!
Good blocks!
Ahhhh.
Alright.
It's alright.
It's cool.
It's one round.
This is Tekken.
Yeah.
This is learning Tekken 100%.
Oh.
She realized I know her counter.
What the fuck was that?
They didn't juke you?
Nice try.
Okay.
Some Naruto shit.
What the fuck?
That's alright.
Just run your shit.
Try your best.
Here we go.
Love that.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Nice.
What?
The hits?
Alright.
Nice.
Good grab.
Oh no.
She got me.
I didn't heal it.
Oh.
Very close.
You ran your game.
You did great.
Honestly.
That was so close.
Yeah.
I don't like to blow smoke.
But that was genuinely...
That was good Tekken.
And that's what happens.
Ahhh.
And we'll clean this one up and then we'll go next.
That was so close.
Yeah.
At the evil run back.
When Gumi is there.
We'll all be laughing.
Yeah.
We'll be fucking loud in that room.
I'll be like, Fucking beat her ass.
Oh.
I don't know what I could have done differently there.
I feel like she adapted so fast too.
Yeah.
She hit you with the hella rage arts.
So like.
I guess just block.
You know.
Call it out.
And then you get a full launch.
Yeah.
And you blocked her lows perfectly.
We just have to mash the four.
And you ducked her the three one thing too.
But again.
Yeah.
But it was good.
You were...
Defensively you were doing great.
I should have alley kicked more.
Maybe.
I should have alley kicked.
Alright.
Next.
Next match.
And for the future.
Just fucking send it.
Just alley kick.
Don't listen to coach.
You don't know what I'm talking about.
This Pikmin thing is the funniest thing I've ever seen.
In my life.
He's immune to fire by the way.
Mmhmm.
Okay.
King battle.
Nice.
Round two.
Oh.
Nice.
Yes!
We are alley kick central.
When you block a back one two.
Back one two and back.
It's unsafe.
Or you can even duck the second and hop kick him.
Sick.
Also if you jab jab he's gonna duck.
You can jab jab hop kick him.
Also after running three he's gonna duck every time right now too.
See?
Yeah, yeah.
He's autopiloting.
I just noticed you're a pig.
We know what he's doing.
Jab jab mid and then running three mid.
That's what you gotta do.
You got this brother.
He might stop now.
He might stop now but it's up to you to recognize it.
Guaranteed.
Get up.
He's doing it every time.
It's an ice break.
Fuck.
I got anxious.
It's okay.
Fuckin' go.
That lean is for you.
Slurp it up.
There's no way.
Mop mop.
Okay.
There's a strike.
Fuckin' Mug'd Giga chad.
Like, jeez.
Fuck yeah.
Dude.
Oh!
He's dead Kony.
Oh my god.
You can mild walk for this.
Well almost dead.
It's fine.
Fuck.
Nice job.
I mean, Kony obviously mused, let's be honest here.
Nice punish.
I haven't gone for that yet.
Nice punish though.
Let's fucking go, baby!
Nice!
KJM is bald!
I agree with it.
He wants to get off that stage.
Even though, yeah, it's a good King stage, but he's also King, so...
I'm gonna pin this KJM.
Remember Kony, back went two.
You go back went two and back.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, that just... if he hits you twice and you block it...
Wop, wop.
And he explodes.
The optimal punish is to duck the second hit and hopkick him for it, but yeah, if we haven't practiced it, just punish it.
All good.
Yeah.
And yeah, he's dead.
He's still a ducker.
1-1 mid.
Boom, baby!
Nice!
Damn, that was good.
Yeah.
Fuck, I tried to Shiny Wizard that.
Nice Sprinkler.
Oh, fuck.
I already broke that.
That was bad.
You just mash him.
That's fine.
Reset.
Act like that didn't even happen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That round did not happen.
So, now you poke, poke, grab.
Nice hop.
Nice.
Fuck!
That's all good.
You got it.
Oh, that's okay.
He's got this.
You got it.
Hit them.
Come on, baby.
Ah, yo.
It's all right.
Yo.
Well done.
Come on, baby!
Oh, nice go!
Nice!
Oh my god, he smashed Punisher.
Look at that damage.
Nooooo!
Oh my god!
He didn't take it!
Let's go!
Wrap it up!
Wrap this shit!
Wrap it up, baby!
Keep that momentum!
Oh my gosh!
Nice grab.
You have heal.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
What else?
He got it!
No!
You're hit!
This is so cool!
There's no way!
You're just different.
I can't believe it.
He's so much better!
You're just different.
Yes!
Hold on.
Holy fuck.
Alley Cat Strike.
That's a new team name.
I can't believe it, dude.
That was incredible.
That was...
That...
Oh my god!
Alley Cat Strike.
That King matchup!
How is it?
I just wasn't alley kicking enough!
I shouldn't have left my Origen!
Next match, let's just send it.
That's what...
If it speaks to you, that's what I'll do.
I gotta put the cuff back on.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god.
God, dude.
It's so fucking...
Okay.
Let's go.
Dude.
All right.
A little bit too nerve-wracking.
Holy shit.
No, these are hard to watch.
For sure, man.
Yeah.
World's hardest watch.
That was...
Oh my god.
That was like the slowest King matchup I've ever seen.
It's so like...
It's like a chess game.
Yeah, dude.
They were playing so like defensive.
Oh, Kony, you gotta press the...
Yeah.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought...
Yeah.
You're good, dude.
I think I pressed it twice.
Sorry.
God.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm so G'd up right now.
They played so defensive and like...
Yeah.
Oh, man.
That was incredible.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm gonna...
He's definitely studied us.
You got this, Kline.
All right.
I wonder what his heart rate was during that match.
Real shit.
Yeah.
Oh, they gotta get heart rate monitors for a Sage Jam Slam 3.
Bro has pop off.
You gotta see it.
Oh, my God.
That was like so close too.
You got this, Kline.
All right.
Time to lock in, brother.
You got this.
Easy.
Kishin.
I believe.
I miss round robin day.
He continues to get up incorrectly.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Round two.
Fight!
Fucking go slime!
Put her at the fucking wall!
Good shit!
Oosh, oosh, oosh, oosh!
What's the answer, young lady?
Eat her up!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Give it a second.
Side walling him.
Counter hit.
We went neutral though.
You got strength, but we went neutral, Drew.
Oh, we got a spring kick.
We got a spring kick to get any damage.
We got to do the destroyer shit.
Okay.
Oh, damn!
Any damage.
We need orange threats.
Oh, shit!
Round three.
Fight!
We get up here.
Good shit.
Nice!
Oh, wow.
Interesting.
Okay, this is fine.
We got a spring kick.
It's all good.
It's one round.
Yeah, you just give him one.
Slap her in the face.
Big whiff punish slide.
Nice!
Is that real?
Yes.
Why doesn't it lead into stuff?
If you block the low, you can launch her for it.
Mmm.
Oh.
Josh is in here.
Final round.
Fight!
Incredible.
Good shoot.
Wall combo.
Okay.
A-doom!
Yeah, I come out sometimes!
Oh, no.
Oh!
Oh, close.
Close.
Very close.
I'm delay a little bit.
Crazy good match.
Very good.
Aw.
You win.
Round one.
Fight!
That's what I'm talking about, baby.
Flipper!
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
But...
Nice.
Oh, I fucked up bad.
It's okay.
Composure.
Back the slime.
Damn it.
Um, you're alive.
Keep in mind, if he's gonna rage art once, he'll probably send it again.
All right.
I have my mix up.
You ready?
Yes.
What?
Why couldn't I get away?
I'm so close.
Oh.
Whatever.
It's all good.
Okay.
I'm panicking.
Oh.
Nice job.
No more G+.
I think she kills me.
Raging shit.
You could've won that.
You ducked that high.
She did.
You could've launched him for it.
Good.
Fucking hell.
Sweet.
Y'all are so good.
I'm gonna...
Nice.
Okay, so I can't G-Club that, it doesn't matter.
I just got outmatched.
Good try, good try.
That's fine, dude.
Alright, Propo, are you ready for your matchup soon?
What the fuck do you mean?
I could lose!
Matt, don't say that!
I'm always ready, yes.
You ready to play against another bear?
This could be a legendary fucking comeback by this guy.
You gotta get out of the lobby, Slime, my friend.
Alright, I'll try.
Yup, just play your best.
Training is already complete.
Oh, if you're wondering, I did throw up by the way.
Oh no!
I guess that's just life.
It's just part of me.
At least one throw up per slam.
My read is down back one, and then I'm gonna do the fucking sweep.
You got this, bro.
Oh, into the stratosphere?
Hold on, I'm gonna hit a funny combo.
Nothing else matters.
Depends how funny it is.
It's pretty funny, dude.
It better be pretty fucking funny.
My read is complete.
I'm gonna
hit a funny combo.
Nothing else matters.
I'm gonna hit a funny combo.
Nice kala, man.
Well done.
Oh
my.
Love gnat.
American reset.
Oh, I hit one plus two.
When he's in heat, he's gonna run in.
Maybe walk around.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't notice that.
Okay.
Skara.
Alright.
Upgrades.
Skara got some upgrades.
Yeah, Skara analyzed.
Yeah, you're blocked and if you just punish those things...
Oh, I know.
Let's fuck the launch too.
Hold on.
Oh my god, I just got fucking told.
That's okay.
Own them for it.
Nice.
He has his potion.
He has it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Upgrades.
I'm just keeping it close.
That was a warm up.
Round one.
Fight.
Good shit.
Nice.
I'm gonna take him.
Does that hurt, Victor?
Good shit.
Good shit, dude.
He doesn't need to have any kids anymore.
Send that, dude.
Good launch.
Punish.
Hell it.
Oh, he's...
He's... Okay.
Oh.
Bon apptit.
Send that.
Nice.
He's back online.
He's risen.
We adapt.
He is fucking risen.
Fight.
It's okay.
No.
He's dead.
Clean.
No.
Nice.
He's dead.
I need to boost heat.
Bounce is still on the table.
That was his heat smash he went for too.
He still got bounce on the table.
Yeah, the floor blast is still on.
Oh, I try to heat boost.
Aw.
Nice try.
NTT.
One round.
Still got time.
Fight.
Final round.
NTT.
Oh my god, he's outplaying me, I'm sorry.
It's all good, it's all good.
Just keep it solid man, just play your game.
What the fuck, Skarra?!
Nice.
Oh yeah!
He has rage.
He's dead.
We blocked that.
Nice!
Good shit!
Oh my god.
Go Matco, come on Matco!
Fucking young man, back to you.
Make him retire!
Change stage if you want.
No, I want him.
Yes,
that's right.
Nice!
Nice launch.
That's it.
Yeah!
Fucking go Jack!
Let's go.
One!
Oh my god, what are these combos?
Good morning.
That's how many sets he's getting.
Fuck you!
That's fucking right!
My god.
This kills, this kills.
Jesus is omnipresent.
Omniscience.
He knows what lies in your heart!
He can see what's in your heart and your mind!
You have sinned!
That was the biggest fuck you ever.
Oh he's dead.
Have you confessed to our lord and savior, Jack Jesus?
He cries for you.
Turns water to blood.
That move is so dumb.
Shining!
Nice!
Send the bomb.
That's the cause for heaven.
The satellite.
Message from God.
You can launch that one.
Kill him.
No!
What are we doing?
That's right!
Boom!
Yeah!
Good job, man.
What are you doing?
Did his break?
Oh my god!
Nice job.
I feel like his- Nice job.
We're fucking tilted off.
What the fuck?
Let's fucking go!
His higher decision making part of his brain just melted off.
He was screaming like an orange.
What the fuck was that, man?
He threw a rod and the engine seized.
Alright.
Bro, pro, are you gonna stay deafened to Fubby Focus?
Brother, we're sorry that we put you in this spot.
You should be.
This is crazy mental right here.
You could've coached me better.
Why does it always come down to this?
This could be...
This could be legendary.
You got this, brother.
Come on, baby.
I believe in you.
If I lose, I mean, it's okay.
It would lose if we rematch them again.
It's fine.
Look, real shit, it's fine if you lose.
No.
Just treat it like a fucking rank set, bro.
It's literally ranked and you're just farming points off of my cake.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You bump into him in rank.
Steve!
I probably just donated you like a thousand bits and it's just talking to you like it's just any other day.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's on Steve?
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that's new.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Got it.
Nice!
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
Round two.
Fight.
Oh.
Bounce him.
Oh, nice.
He's in the corner.
Uh-oh.
What a combo!
Steven!
Throw him that fucking wand!
He's dead.
Unbelievable.
Un-fucking-lievable, dude.
Oh, he's so good.
Holy shit!
All right.
Okay, okay, okay.
There we go, baby.
I was like, isn't that a lepick?
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
Over here.
Mm.
Come on.
He's dead.
Oh, he's dead.
Smash.
It's over.
Woo!
Yes!
That's wall.
Ooh.
It's this big into the shins.
Oh my god.
That's gonna hurt.
That's the handles.
Nice.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, wow.
True, true.
Yeah.
Oh, that's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh, that kick missed.
Oh, you fucking beat his ass, hunk.
Put him on the wall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make sure he never leaves.
Next!
Come on.
Isn't that a big counter hit?
What else?
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
What is that?
You just rolled it.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
I think there's a reason we're the top team, dude.
Oh my god.
I think there's a fucking reason we're the favorites.
How?
Oh my god.
If you taught me that, I could've beat you.
Spider -Man, push him from the top rope.
He's like, get off that stage.
Get off that up-heel-ing mansion.
He's like, get me out of the king's house.
I'm changing characters.
He's like, you're gonna put me against the wall?
Big mistake.
Get me out of that.
That's king's mansion.
No, get me out of there.
Yeah.
Oh my god, dude.
The keys to the kingdom.
Oh my god.
I've never seen that.
I don't think he's gonna play Steve again.
Bear time.
Dude, you got it.
Alright, you're on a training ground.
You got some walls here.
Mm-hmm.
Alright.
Good luck, dude.
Let's go.
Bear.
Wait, what character is this?
It's a bear.
Slime, it's time for you to take some notes.
Okay, not these notes, though, because he's getting destroyed.
Nice.
Oh.
Yes.
Nice job.
Nice.
He's so fucking...
I mean, he's like...
Oh my god.
That's our coach.
Nice job.
It's just, it's beautiful.
The things that I see today.
Yeah.
It's gold.
I lost on purpose so we could see this.
Is it still worth it?
Yeah.
I sandbagged on purpose.
Good shit.
Nice.
Do it again.
These guys are gaming.
There's some fucking rock, paper, scissors right now.
He chose rock and he's winning.
Any rock mains?
Oh, rock mains.
Rock beats everything.
Let's go, baby.
Yes.
Let's fucking go.
Why can't you just always throw rock?
Exactly.
Oh my god, dude.
Like, what can paper do?
Rock can just be sharper than paper.
That's legendary.
That float was also legendary, honestly.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That punish.
That's the same way you ended it last time.
Blocked on rock in hopkick.
Succeeded training.
Ground punish.
Oh my god.
That is...
That's the exact same way you won.
You're welcome that I lost and won't get this game.
He does it every time, Ian.
He does it every time.
He dropped his combo off the doria.
He could've killed him.
Oh my god.
He dropped it.
Swappy stages does nothing.
Good fucking shit, dude.
Seriously.
Unbelievable.
Nobody does it like him.
Nobody does it.
That was sick.
Oh man.
My heart is pumping.
I saw you go for that cheeky exploder.
I'm like bro thing.
He's trying to blow him up And did you see how we worked that the Kings gamma howl against the running bear thing?
Yo, yeah doing that move because King absorbed it and then punched him upside the head Good fucking shit dude.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking go.
So fucking proud of you dude.
So fucking proud of you.
Good shit.
I'm fucking shivering.
I can't believe we watched that.
Let us out of here.
I can't believe it.
We farmed the content.
Sejam's happy.
I'm not happy yet.
I'm bringing up the other match.
Let me see.
Alright, I got it.
Oh my god.
Piss it all out.
And then we play against Tone.
FD just beat boxbox.
You know, you're on the way Brawl Pro.
Dude, everything's going to coach's match.
This one is too.
This slam is so much more fucking scary.
The teams are a little too close.
They are.
Oh my god.
He's just bringing it up.
I don't know if it's like nerves or anything.
But like, holy shit.
Who won against Tone and V?
Probably Tone.
Oh, they're about to play right now.
Oh shit.
Oh wow.
Oh, so we are streaming that.
So they were just watching us.
Were we on stream?
Were we?
I fucking hope so.
I hope the people get to look at what just occurred.
No, it was Signify versus Boxbox on stream.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
I guess I'll restream Boxbox's POV.
Oh my god, this should have been streamed.
Yeah, I don't know what they were cooking.
What were they thinking?
But they got fucked.
Yeah, how much we were fucking doing.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I would like Tony to lose.
Actually, both of these guys have speedkicks coaching them how to beat me.
And it's annoying.
It doesn't even matter who wins.
What do they have against you?
What did you do to them?
I beat them day one.
Dude, they're all talking mad shit.
They're like, blood loss to Raiditz.
And then everyone else lost to Raiditz.
And it's like, dude...
Oh, no, no, no.
Kaiser, Kaiser.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tony was like, yeah, he was giving me shit for losing to Kaiser.
And he gets too owed.
And Kaiser's like, what did you say fuck me for?
Yeah.
Oh my.
Actually the most nerve-wracking games so far.
I miss round robins.
I want Tony to win because I want the Josh run back.
Sure.
Yeah, true.
Fair enough.
Tony did win.
I just checked the bot.
Tony won?
The coach match.
The coach match is going on right now.
Yeah, yeah, it's a coach match.
Who do we want to win?
Fi or Tone?
I think we want Fi to win.
Because Tone's the strongest.
I think it's easier, yeah.
It's way easier for us if Fi wins.
Like, without, you know, respectfully, Kat is new.
Tony's team is pretty annoying.
Like, that's the ESAM team, I think, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tone's the ESAM team.
Literally no offense, Doki, but ESAM will smoke every person.
No, 100%.
I agree.
By definition, we want Fi to win.
Because that doesn't mean that they get a guaranteed one win, you know?
Yeah.
And it's about to fucking happen.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking go, Fi!
It's 2-2 right now!
10-fit combo.
Hollywood, FiDX.
Guys, you guys want to watch it?
ESAM is auto 1-0, and then Raidit's fucked me up, and like, you know, drag is a huge issue for me, so...
Nice!
We're watching the Fi match right now, chat.
He's cooking this, man, dude.
Oh my god, Fi!
Fi's downloaded him!
Good outs!
Oh, that should've worked.
Oh my god!
That perfect 1-0!
With the cat, Drew!
That was a crazy counter hit.
Wait, but then if like...
Okay, but like...
That means Tone would be in loser bracket, so we might play against Tone if Fi beats us.
Yeah, definitely.
If they lose, we could still play him again, yeah.
But we would rather fight Fi than...
Fi to get into Grants.
Yeah, okay.
We'd rather get that, cause then we...
So right now we're guaranteed at least third.
If we win again, we're guaranteed second.
Which means if we win one more set, we go to EVO.
Uh, theoretically.
No one cancels out, dude.
If you win, then take your tickets away!
We all stay home.
Oh, MaV!
So we really want Fi to win.
Alright.
Oh
wow, that's a full combo.
Nice.
Dude, Lili's...
Oh, what a man.
Dude, Lili is fucking insane.
I think the damage is just absurdly high on her.
That's the EVO Japan character, man.
Was Fi sandbagging and turning round robins?
Like, what?
Where was this?
He just analyzed and studied.
Oh, okay.
I was like, where the fuck was this?
This is, you know, just kind of a read on my part.
I get the vibe Fi is...
very...
anxious about his...
Because he's the Tekken YouTube guy.
And if he doesn't perform, he thinks people are gonna care about that.
Like, oh, if you're so good, why aren't you...
You know what I mean?
I think he takes that seriously.
He hasn't learned...
He hasn't fully embraced the skill of don't look at comments yet.
It's hard.
It is hard.
You can revel in it.
You can get lost.
Also, sponsor curse.
Sponsor curse.
True.
He just got sponsored too.
Like, everyone's looking.
Wait, who did he get sponsored by?
DSP?
Yeah, this guy's Toku.
Oh!
He got to 100k within 4 or 5 months.
That's why it was maybe hard to get used to all the comments.
Yeah.
It's something everyone who kind of blows up has to learn.
Unless you're already in the know.
Just turn off the monitor.
Oh my god.
Good block!
Tone's been analyzing the wrong coach.
Oh my god.
Tone's fucking desperate.
I mean, he did a 1-2-4 there too.
You could've ducked it.
Good shit.
One more.
Nice!
Why is Lily allergic to this glowing Bryan?
Oh my god.
Oh, that's gonna break the floor.
Come on, Fii.
One more.
Tone with the wall is so scary, dude.
Oh, that was a jet upper.
He fucked up.
He could've won.
No, these guys have a lot of pressure too.
Yeah, they're scared.
I'll say no matter what.
Tone's like the super top seed, so he's got all the eyes on him.
And I think Tone wants to win this more than anybody else.
Yeah, he wanted me on his team and shit.
He was like, hey Matt, you wanna fucking...
Why does Tone wanna win so badly?
I was hanging out in his Twitch chat and he was like, yo, you wanna be part of my team?
I was like, uh...
He tried to poach you from the team?
Oh my god!
If he was trying to poach, he should've offered money.
I mean, respect, but like...
It's respect, for sure.
You're a commodity.
Yeah, you should've taken bribes.
You're a hot commodity.
I'm a free agent.
Bro is Otani of the slims.
Sign him up.
Oh my god.
Heat battle, heat battle.
Is this captain left?
Oh my fucking god!
Did he do it?
No way!
Oh my god!
That's so close!
Fuck, man.
Fiend needs to win for us, man.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Yo.
Why are the slims so close though?
Dude, every game going to coach match, bro.
Yeah.
This is insane.
Coach match, final finals, like, except for you, you dominated.
No, that would be stupid.
If it's a coach match to get first, that would be dumb.
I would just walk off.
Y'all got it.
I'm not putting myself through that.
What?
Not for me?
For my ticket!
Guys, coach doesn't care.
Is this tournament rules just a rant?
Is this a random stage selection?
Yeah, that's TWT rules.
You can't counter pick stage.
It has to be random.
That's insane.
As a Smash player, that's absurd.
Yeah.
That's what I was going to say.
Because of you two.
But then again, Kony, Jack8 and Big Guy, good at the game.
Yeah, it's a different world.
I'm all adapting now.
He's my boss.
Fiend's playing mad defensive now.
Oh, man.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
This is so nerve-wracking.
I'm watching this and I'm scared.
Yeah, I'm not slaying.
Yeah.
Imagine how they feel.
Look, Fiend needs to duck that 1-2-4.
Tony keeps spamming.
Nice.
Oh, he's dead.
No!
He's panicking.
Really?
Damn it.
They're making mistakes now.
They're scared.
Lock in, Fiend.
Lock in, dude.
How long you've been playing, how professional you are, nerves will change.
Oh, man.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Why is that hitting?
Oh, no.
This might be a done deal.
Oh, I think...
He's playing so defensively now.
I think when he's like...
kind of tilted, he reverts back to Tekken 7 style.
What's Tekken 7 style?
Very defensive, back dashing.
Tekken 8 is very aggressive.
You have to go in if you want to win.
Nice.
Counter hit Fiend.
Let's fucking go, dude.
Oh.
Voila.
Oh!
Cook this man!
Oh, that is minus 13.
Punish that, Fiend.
Okay, nice power crush.
It ain't over till it's over.
Bring it back.
I cannot imagine what their team is going through right now.
Yeah.
This rock, paper, scissors, man.
No.
Tone is winning the rock, paper, scissors.
Oh, my fucking god.
I'm so scared.
I want to close my eyes.
I'm closing my eyes.
It's over.
If he didn't punish...
No!
If he didn't punish that, he's going to tilt himself.
He needs to get away from the wall.
It's over, GG.
It's over.
That's it.
Goodbye, Fee.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Well, time to fight Tone.
Well, all that means is that we get smoked by Tony's team and then we fight FeeDX's team and lose next time.
Wait a minute.
Hold on.
We could win.
We need some... Oh, god.
We're in need of a vehicle, man.
He said, oh, god.
Oh, god.
I see.
Brian is cheap as fuck, dude.
At the wall.
Oh, my god.
This is truly...
so nerve-wracking.
Hey, we got at least third, though.
That's big.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Hey, I'm...
I told BrawlPro last night, we were talking, I was like, as long as I do my job, like, I can... that's all I can focus on, right?
All we can focus on are our sets.
And obviously, we want to win for everybody, but it's like, all you can do is work it about your game.
You know what I mean?
We're trying to do it as a team.
So... For real?
For real?
We all gotta do it together.
Yeah.
Do we get, like, an intermission going straight in?
I don't know.
I'mma tell them, let us run to the bathroom.
Because I'm at the ghost at NYK's.
But I wanted to watch that set.
I'm about to piss his pants.
Oh.
Oh, they are going to the losers right now, on the mainstream though.
So we're most likely, we might have to join the lobby soon.
Yeah.
Oh.
I don't even play Tekken.
Four straight coach matches.
I'm just as nervous.
Oh.
Damn.
I'm freaking it.
Alright, I will be right back, fellas.
Oh my god.
That was so nervous.
I think, like...
I think I definitely, like...
Against Gumi, I definitely hesitated so much.
Because I started thinking too much.
I think it's because, like...
Uh...
I was, like...
I was just thinking too much in that last game.
And then, yeah.
I got into my own head.
And I fucked up.
Yeah.
I kept thinking about block, block, block.
So then I forgot how to be aggressive.
Because, like, that's how I won rounds.
When I was more aggressive.
But, oh my god.
I was, like...
I was too nervous there.
Yeah.
I just gotta relax.
My hands...
My fingers during the round robins...
My fingers never shook.
I was so, like...
I was technically, like, relaxed during the round robins.
But this is, like, the first time...
My hands actually were shaking.
Like...
I was actually shaking.
And I was, like...
Yeah.
The pressure got to me.
But, like...
It was still close.
I just ended up, like, not punishing or doing damage.
I got defense.
I defended.
But I didn't do anything after defending.
But!
Maybe I purposely lost so we can get that sick-ass brawl pro match.
I don't know.
If I...
If I won...
We wouldn't have saw the match we saw today.
I'm just saying.
Guys.
We wouldn't have been able to see some sick-ass Tekken if we...
The...
The wall jumps and everything?
Come on!
We wouldn't have that content, guys.
It was fate.
Yeah.
I sandbagged so we could see that sick-ass Tekken.
That wall jump was fucking sick!
Come on, guys!
If I won, we wouldn't see that.
It was for the content.
Focus on trying to win.
Okay, guys.
We're not winning against ESAM.
I'm like the resident punching bag.
I'm the punching bag for the team.
Like, we're not...
Bro!
ESAM is a fucking...
Who the fuck is ESAM?
Fuck, let this fucking Super Smash Bros Pro play fourth seed.
Like, who the fuck allowed this to happen?
This person is a Smash Bros Pro player.
It's just Smash.
Just think it's right.
Oh, do the cheesy stuff I do in ranked.
Bro, I hate playing against Laws.
Hey, did we lose matches first before our match?
I thought they...
So, we got a little...
Oh, there you go.
I'll pretend this is...
Bro, this is ESAM right here.
Oh my god, perfect ESAM.
He doesn't slide.
It's not him.
He needs to slide.
Round 2.
Fight.
The moment he starts sliding, then it's ESAM.
Because ESAM fucking abuses that shit.
So much.
It's actually crazy.
Goodbye.
Boom.
Oh shit.
He actually...
No!
ESAM, please!
ESAM!
Okay.
Leave me alone.
Hahaha.
Okay.
If he abuses it, he's predictable.
But he knows!
That's the thing!
He knows if I start blocking, he fucking...
He swaps these...
He actually adapts!
Because he comes from fighting games!
And they actually adapt!
I don't adapt!
That's the thing!
I'll be like, what?
You mean I have to change my moveset?
What?
What do you mean?
I have to change how I play.
I lose that.
Attack!
I can block.
See?
I blocked.
But what does blocking do for me?
Look at that.
I blocked and I started getting shit on.
Hahaha.
Guys!
Who told me to block?
Look, I blocked.
See?
I blocked.
There we go.
Why the fuck did you do that?
What?
I was low!
Oh my god.
Get away from me!
Go back to Smash Brothers!
Go back!
You're fucking bald!
Yay.
Alright, back.
Sorry about that.
Hahaha.
Welcome back.
Alright, we gotta play against Lars.
Not really.
Alright.
I'm watching this stream now.
I'm watching this FG versus Topp.
C U P E S M!
Hahaha.
Oh wait, he's purple, man!
Just like him!
Just like E S M!
He's purple too!
He just came from a local, so I know he's playing more than me.
He got the local buff.
Oh my god.
He's just like him!
Box was seven feet tall until yesterday.
That matters.
For real, by the way, good shit.
In that set, guys.
Yeah.
We're fucking top three.
Oh god.
We're in the money.
I'm sorry!
I mean, we just have to win one more set, whether it's winners or losers in the top two.
This happened to us in the first lane.
So... yeah.
We can do it, bro.
Okay.
Here we go.
Boom!
My biggest issue with tournaments is like, I know we can win.
Like, I know I can beat anybody.
I know you guys can beat anybody, but will we?
Right?
There we go.
That's the scary part.
Who's better today?
Boom!
That's fucking right!
ESEM!
Go back to your original game!
Okay.
At least my company likes the game I play.
Wait, that's fucked up.
At least the game company likes it when I play their video game.
You know it's true.
Apex never shut down anything.
That's why you have to use Tekken as a crutch!
I don't know, Ysab, I don't know who you are, it's just Tekken.
They are talking about anti-MATMAN strats on Boxstream.
Why?
Okay, rematch.
He just said he has it.
It's so funny that they are trying so hard to prep for you specifically.
Why man?
I'm just trying to play games.
Because you are the nuclear weapon!
You are the bomb!
Oh my god, please, I don't want to die!
I'm sorry.
I don't adapt!
This might be the time where they have literally had enough slams and enough time where they have latched on.
Again, specifically me.
Specifically me and my playstyle.
But you adapted as far as I did though.
You adapted with the gamma howl.
That was the biggest fuck you I have ever seen.
No!
Fuck you.
I gotta watch that back.
It's funny to see different styles because I kind of run over Zentreya because I just put on pressure.
But James is slower, which is better against Raiditz but worse against Zentreya because he gives her more opportunities to...
Get away from me.
Yeah, everyone has their own style.
It can work.
Yeah.
Boom!
Zentreya is up one though.
Yeah, that was ugly can-can style.
She is popping it too much.
Oh, she has to engage her Holy No!
You are not supposed to grab.
You just do kicks.
That's all fuck.
Ok, I did not think you would.
I thought you are gonna duck.
Please take me back to the other side.
Please.
I don't know how to play this.
That's nasty man.
You should.
You should do it.
He does the hop kick into the wall, into the choke.
That's fucked up.
That's a drop kick.
I'm angry.
I'm fucking mad.
Oh what?
No!
Let me leave!
Let me get up!
What the fuck is this?
This is how it's gonna go with me and Ysab.
It is just the future.
Definitely.
It shows the way he plays.
Like traditional fighters.
You know what I mean?
We saw the future.
Well it's just block and then maybe this.
If he starts sliding I just do this.
But like it's so... the timing is a lot.
His rage clip.
He never wants that to happen again.
He's just trying to stop that forever.
If you take one set from Ysab he has to unplug.
I did.
We talked about it yesterday.
The wizard is interesting.
I didn't even think of... Oh my god.
He's doing that a lot.
He counter hit her in between her rage drive.
I think.
That was crazy.
I don't know.
For some reason I thought it worked.
I don't think it.
I was like that would be funny if it works.
You know?
I just thought it would be funny if it worked again.
This one might be done.
Might be the end of KFM.
Actually no.
They are up 1-0.
This would just make it 1-1.
No!
I'm sorry!
I'd rather not fight in 1K again.
This shit is stressful.
AHHHH!
Stressful as fuck.
Yeah.
I'd rather fight in 1K than lose 2K.
Punish though.
Good hop.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh I don't get this.
Please.
Oh.
Sorry.
Scream that stress away.
I have to fight Ysab!
Woah!
Oh I missed.
Oh.
So you can duck that one.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
That dropped probably.
It bounced.
Wow.
Yeah.
Therapy.
She's clutching it out.
Yup.
Oh my god.
Bro.
I watched some of her sets back.
What the fuck?
I'm blocking!
I can just smash!
I was just saying.
Fuck.
He blocked.
Okay.
Yeah.
She was toxic.
Jintrae was saying some shit dude.
What?
Really?
She was being toxic.
Yes.
She was like get that spammer out of the fucking lobby.
Spamming fucking cringe.
I was like Jesus.
Like oh my god.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
That's just like you after you beat Eerop.
True.
I'm fucking better than you dude.
Well I was better than you though.
This is it.
Fuck this.
Fuck doing actual combos.
I was better though.
This is the way to go.
I was so annoyed.
You were just doing the same fucking.
Fuck doing this.
I hate losing the box.
Actual combos.
But she did.
She came back around after a second.
She was like I was you know.
It was just like a release of tension.
She won.
One more.
Okay.
This is.
Fuck this.
I don't need combos to sound like this.
I think James is better than him dude.
I think James gets nervous bro.
Like.
Bro.
I don't know.
Who cares about combos.
Why am I trying new things.
Do what you.
What you did to get to this Eerop.
When the alligator can sue you.
He's pressure now.
Oh yeah.
More pressure.
Doki it.
You fucking listen to people.
Trying to block and everything.
Do what got you into this Eerop.
Do what's right.
Do fucking.
Do what's fucking right.
Don't let them tell you what to do.
Just do what's fucking right.
Oh my god.
I just.
I just want to see if she finished that combo.
Oh.
I'm behind.
She dropped it.
Oh.
Okay.
Do what comes naturally.
Doki.
You thought too much.
Against Gumi.
You were thinking.
And then you didn't.
All you did was block.
You fucking.
You were.
You were not.
You were known as 30 defense Doki.
Not.
It was not meant to be.
The moment I started attacking it was over.
I was like, you're right.
My ass is getting twirled.
Oh my god.
He wishes he was mad.
You need a punish here!
Zen!
Oh my god, dude.
There's no way.
He wishes he was just like him!
There's no way, dude.
You're not like Jack!
Jesus!
You're cooking this man.
You're so fucking bad!
Get alley kicked!
I'm watching if he goes up to like...
No one needs defense!
Defense is for losers!
You got to win with my different defending!
Get fucked off!
No one needs defense!
I didn't know Zen got this good this quickly.
She's in Garu, dude!
Bro!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, he's starting to do a little parry.
I guess they haven't been playing ranked.
He's just been practicing.
Yeah.
Yes.
Damn, James Cook.
Wow.
Final game.
Final round.
No.
Bro, why are you defending?
Can-can there.
He goes for burning knuckle.
James is like... disrespectful.
Okay.
He's an animal, dude.
He did that fucking...
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone!
No way.
He's spamming.
He's... Oh my god.
Bam!
They didn't laugh at that.
Fuck off!
Crazy.
That's fucking right.
He's such a nerd.
Freaking James Chensor.
Elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow.
No, no.
He broke my wall... my floor!
That was mad close.
He broke my floor!
Did you see the chat?
My floor!
Jesus.
The main one?
In the Discord chat.
Wait...
Look at stage one.
Blocking is cringe.
The trades have learned from combos.
Jesus.
The tag's only weakness.
Oh my god.
I see it, dude.
See, it's not- Blocking is fucking stupid.
Blocking is so fucking stupid.
Those two elbows look like a good combo to me.
Blocking is so stupid.
That looked like a combo.
A little bit of 1-2 action.
Jack wouldn't have fucking...
Matt would not have given me a round.
That's all I'm saying.
Matt would not have given me that round.
Oh, adaption.
It's spamming.
Oh no!
No!
Oh my god, what is that?
What's that kek, bro?
Jack Jesus, exactly.
Not my Jack Jesus.
Jack Jesus would have swept me so hard.
You know what's funny?
If you don't have the window selected, the kek doesn't move.
Hold on, let me see if I can...
There it goes.
But then...
Oh my god.
Fighting games are fun.
Funny, bro.
It's a good time.
It's like super stressful, but super fun too.
After this game, we're gonna live watch with the homies.
The false prophet.
Yeah, Matt would have gotten 4 perfects out of there.
My chat is out of there.
Yeah, if this was Matt, he would have let me start up.
What is wrong with you?
And you trying to learn Jack?
If you can't get 3 perfects in a row, uninstall now.
Royciato, man.
He should be the first seed.
Oh my god.
Dude, Fairlight is also nuts.
I knew blocking was never it.
But that guy is...
He spams a lot of shoulder and he gets away with it.
In his tier.
We gotta launch that shit.
Like if he did it on slime once, slime kills him.
Like more than once.
Like 80% if he has heat and a wall.
Oh, Roy beat Fairlight apparently.
Okay.
Don't learn all the moves.
Just learn the moves you can take it in.
Feels like he's supposed to be the shoto, right?
He's like the most basic character.
But he's got these weird fucking...
corny...
It doesn't feel like I'm losing to a shoto.
You know what I mean?
It's hard to explain.
Yeah, he's like the weirdest shoto I've ever seen in a funny show.
No!
Doki, why are you trying to do blocking again?
Have you not learned anything?
Ishimas are really not comparable.
I just mean like as the default characters.
Oh my god, Doki!
Look what happened to you!
Oh!
Guys, I need to stop blocking.
It's a good ending.
I need to stop blocking, guys.
It's actually messing me up.
The good timeline.
It all worked out.
It's all... it actually is messing me up.
Stop learning blocking!
He knows what's up.
Oh shit.
I punched the wrong thing.
Tekken is weird because the poster boys are the hard characters.
Oh, that's a good point.
Because it's Free Fighter like Ken for you.
Okay, there you go.
Not easy, but like...
Yeah, Kaze is probably the most demanding.
He's been the poster boy forever.
And now it's Jin.
He's easier but still.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
He's like the easiest Tekken character.
Come on, let me punch you.
Let me punch you!
Maybe Victor.
Is there like a legacy like this character?
Boom!
Paul has a high skill ceiling.
But I feel like new players can pick him up though.
That's fucking right!
But I feel like that's a really good design.
When new players can pick him up but the ceiling is still very high.
I ducked!
I'm gonna fucking step you on the crouch!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I don't disagree bro.
King is not...
No, please.
Do my thing.
He's good to pick up.
He's not the easiest to optimize though.
You gotta land all your blue sparks and stuff.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that!
I didn't mean to do that!
I didn't mean to pick it up!
I can't get carried away with the grabs.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay, but what if I do that?
I genuinely can't fathom how you guys play so many grabs.
My brain can't...
Like, how does your brain work that fast?
It's crazy to me.
It's just the pace of the game, really.
Okay.
How was I too slow for this?
Look at the hands.
That's crazy.
Well, you can judge the situation also.
Because Giant Swing comes out faster than the others.
So, MYK, you're the best.
I'm sorry.
I punch you!
Oh, I don't punch you!
I pressed the wrong one!
Leave me alone!
And also habits.
What grab do they like to go for?
At what distance, I guess?
Oh, I didn't buffer it because I'm...
Oh, I'm not gaming anymore!
I mean, I know that...
There you go.
...people set up training regiments for hand stuff.
And I feel like you can do that for like...
...six hours.
Maybe you'll be locked in, but...
Yeah, if you do it 15 minutes a day for a week, I don't see you not getting better at that.
Oh my god, how does he fucking just jab?
Such an easy tech to get used to.
Our reaction time is...
Okay, nice.
I got that.
I actually died...intentionally!
Slime was doing it yesterday, the day we were here.
Oh, what the fuck?
He just grabbed me.
That should be illegal.
Yeah, 1-1.
Oh, no!
Oh, dude, yeah, don't turn that.
It was funny, but chat makes it so much fun.
Blocking is for fucking pussies.
Okay, let's watch...
Let's watch the match with everybody.
Alright, let me grab the stream.
Cool.
Okay, where is the stream?
Wow, my chat's so much better now.
Say jam.
Twitch.
Alright, here you go.
Pin message.
Are they tied right now?
I'm watching it now.
Look at the bottom.
The check mark's at the bottom.
They'll tell you...
Oh, it's 1-1.
Yeah, this shit's close.
Everything's going final game.
It's unbelievable.
Which is crazy, dude!
Who do we want to win?
Uh...
Roy Chiotto's a nerd, so the other team.
Oh, okay.
Wait, Team NYK?
Well...
NYK brought us close.
The only person we didn't...
On Roy's team, didn't we only lose to Roy?
No, I lost to Logan.
Logan beat me once, and then I lost to Logan on the second.
Because he hard studied King.
Oh, I see.
So she beat him first time, he beat her second time.
I'll beat Zentrea probably.
I mean, I assume.
You know, Roy's very good.
I forget who the fourth seed on KFM's team is.
Did we beat him?
That's Amaz.
Yeah, oh yeah, he beat...
Yeah, he was the one that beat him.
Yeah.
Because they have King players to actively play against.
Hey, best case scenario...
We fight...
Scar's team.
So we want NYK to win?
Yeah.
I don't want to fight James Chen again, man.
Yeah, but like...
I'm 2-0, bro.
Alright, alright.
For the one time, you guys gotta carry my ass.
But...
Logan hard studied.
For the one time, I really need you guys.
Yeah, we got it.
We'll lock in.
I mean, this isn't losers.
This is assuming we lose to Tony.
We could just win and beat Tony.
That's funny.
I was just in replay system studying the fuck out of BoxBox.
It's their fucking fourth...
It's fucking ESAM, dude.
It's so annoying.
What is he doing there?
Okay, if I take like one round off of him, I should just win.
I know.
You should just tell him that.
I should just win.
That's not fair.
I told Sajam that after the whole thing is done, I want to do an exhibition Tekken Ball.
An exhibition Tekken Ball?
An exhibition Tekken Ball.
I don't know who wants to Tekken Ball me, but someone's gonna get balled on.
Kaiser and Fear also won one.
That's crazy, dude.
Dude.
Who are we playing against if we lose to Tone?
I don't know if we know yet.
We don't know.
The winner of this bracket has to play a different person, right?
I think so.
So I've almost forgotten.
Loser this gets fifth and are out.
Oh, okay.
So then yeah, it's gonna be them versus whoever.
Whoever wins the other loser bracket, right?
And then we fight them.
Who's in the...
Okay, so out of all four teams...
I cannot believe that hit the wall.
Jeez.
Right?
I don't even know who is in losers right now.
I mean, obviously Fii.
It's Fii versus Kaiser.
Fii, Kaiser, and then Miles and MYK.
Oh, and Maz is like fucking destroying Scar right now.
He's destroying this man, yeah.
Fucking hate him, Maz.
Alyssa is a crack character.
Like, when Matt loses to Maz, that's supposed to be a 60-40, I think, for Jack.
But that's why it hurts more when you lose.
And you got the favorable matchup a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Yeah.
But I just didn't know the matchup last time.
I've gone and studied.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
But now we do, so we win.
Bro Pro actually coached him this time.
I saw it with my own hands.
Parentheses, I will still lose.
I saw it.
Doki was there.
She heard it.
Yeah, I'm the witness.
Oh, my God.
Fucking explosion.
Why is Scar getting hit by that hop kick like that?
Because no one knows Alyssa, bro.
What the fuck kind of character has a double-hitting hop kick?
Why is she always in the air?
Rip her wings out.
Like that shit happened to... no one's played Tekken 7 before in their life.
Let's be real here.
Everyone who's played Tekken 7 is old as fuck in your chat.
Whoa, who played Tekken 7?
Actually, I played Tekken 7.
Oh, okay.
So you're old as fuck.
I played it for like a hundred hours.
This has got to hurt.
Like being the guy that like... like if Scar loses this...
Oh, whoa.
Like the cup doesn't knock you out of the tournament.
You're out of... you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's got to suck.
Oh, my God.
That's... uh-oh.
Dude, I am telling you that team is fucking godlike.
No.
Yeah, but then they still have to fight the other... the other two.
Or like the other what?
Team.
Yeah.
I think I can take a Moz now.
I know you can take him.
I shouldn't have lost the first one, but...
Yeah, you can absolutely win.
Could be a Scar situation where he fucks on me, you know?
Oh, remember at the wall, he loves that down four one plus two.
Scar doesn't know how to punish, so that sucks for him.
Wait, so how do I block the slide from Law again?
You just block... when he's mid-range and crouching from mid-range, he's probably going to do it.
Then you just... you just down back.
Down back.
Okay.
Yeah, you block low and then you mash four.
Just like Yoshi.
Okay.
And then he'll go in the air and then you can decide what to do after.
It's not enough time to tell you.
But technically that's supposed to lead into a combo.
If you block the slide, it's supposed to be a combo.
Alley kick will punish it.
When you block it, spam alley kick.
Oh.
If you want.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Spam alley kick.
Okay.
All I do is just spam alley kick, so okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Block it.
Oh, when you block it, it's coming?
Block it if you think it's coming, and then afterwards, spam the fuck out of alley kick.
Oh, he might win from this.
Dude, look how many times he does the fucking...
I'm telling you, man.
Yeah.
It's the most flow chart Alyssa I've ever seen in my life.
I wonder if they talk shit.
Isn't it annoying when you...
Dude, I'm sure they do.
Because like you and I were talking last night, you know?
Like I fucking...
You know how I feel.
Dude, all this fucking jackdaws and spam grabs, like you got...
I know they said all I do is spam grabs too at some point.
But we're playing King.
You're King!
That's all we do.
That's fucking mad shit.
We are talking mad shit.
I know.
100%.
Everybody does.
I already told my chat that like at least like... at least Apex supports tournaments.
Oh my god, the damage, dude.
Victory is insane.
Oh, the 1-1 needs to be ducked.
Look at that gray life.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, Skarad doesn't know.
He blocked.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, he got it.
Wait.
Signs of life.
Wait a minute.
8 hours!
He's waking up!
Almost.
Those are four highs in a row.
That's minus 14.
That low mid.
That's like minus 30.
I went in the replay system.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Skarad.
Oh.
Goodbye.
It's over.
At least he knows how I felt.
He knows how I felt.
Goodbye, MYK.
This is the first team where it's not a coach match, right?
Yeah, yeah.
They were able to 3-0.
Damn, that's gotta hurt.
To be fair, they had to play against... what's his name?
Roy?
Roy Chihata, which is a free win for them.
Yeah.
It feels like a lot of like... a lot of the tiers have a free win in their tier.
You know what I mean?
Like they got the first seed.
Roy Chihata, they got the third seed.
You guys got me.
Not Zico, but you know.
Let's be real.
Talk your shit.
All right.
And we're playing next, right?
No, I think it's them.
The person who just won, KawaiiFaceMiles versus whoever won FDX.
Oh, so it was two loser brackets and then us.
I don't know.
Is it?
Oh, they're going all the way up?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I'm not sure.
Is this a bracket?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So KFM just won.
FDX versus Kaiser is going to happen and then we're fighting them.
Okay.
Or... or not.
No, wait.
We have to wait for all the streams.
They were playing at the same time.
Both loser brackets, we're playing at the same time.
I'm just fucking stupid.
They're playing...
We're going to fight Tone's, right?
We're fighting Tone's team.
Yeah.
After that, we'll fight whoever wins this.
Assuming we lose quarter.
Assuming we lose, which we shouldn't.
Yeah.
Because Kony is going to clutch it for us.
I might.
I mean, I might.
True?
FDX versus Monkey D Animal.
Oh, Eddie, moment.
Oh my God.
All right.
Well, we can all tap out of this one.
Okay.
We have that.
Here, the bracket, I guess I can post it in our chat.
Okay.
There you go.
What's the score on the other...
The other...
Loser bracket.
Does anyone know what the score is on the other loser bracket?
Or is it in the...
Oh, it's in the challenge.
Okay.
Yeah.
The challenge.
Challenge.
I didn't know people used challenge still.
They didn't even update it.
Womp womp.
I don't know who's winning.
Chat, who's winning right now?
I don't know.
They don't have the over rank.
V or Kaiser.
Don't worry.
My chat is winning.
Chat will stream snipe for me.
Oh, they pulled up the overlay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
It's the wrong one.
Oh.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yo, FD6 is on Eddy, not Zaf.
Yeah, but he was Zaf against BoxBox.
I think it's just literally a toss up.
Oh, V is winning apparently.
Dude.
V is team.
Do you know about the 3-3-3?
Yeah.
Not really.
What the fuck do you mean not really, dude?
What the fuck do you mean?
We never went over it.
Bro, but you've watched the thread.
That three guy.
No, I did not.
I watched him for like five seconds.
I was like, oh, no.
And then I fucking clicked off.
That's all you need, bro.
That's all you need.
No, it is not.
Look at him go.
He's fucking going nasty with it.
Is he really?
No, he's not spamming threes anymore.
Oh, God.
He's so fly.
Isn't it like there's a fucking high somewhere or some shit?
No punish.
This guy just doesn't know the matchup.
I'm not gonna play.
Rest in peace, shifter.
We're currently just watching the Sagem stream because we're not playing yet.
We're not playing yet.
So we're just watching who's going to win up this matchup.
What a copy past it.
To be fair, you have to have very high IQ to press 3S3D.
The timing is extremely subtle and with a solid grasp of frame data.
Most of the kicks were with.
There's also 3D.
He's optimistic outlook, which is definitely woven into his kicks.
His personal philosophy draws heavily from Jose literature.
For instance, the fans understand this stuff.
The intellectual capacity to truly appreciate the difficulty of hitting the combo to realize that it's not just hard.
Okay, that's good.
Whoever wrote that.
Sorry, I had to go watch a clip of MYK going home.
The whole thing was going off on me.
It was funny.
It's not...
It's just not hard.
I feel so bad for MYK.
Getting third in the last one.
Going...
Fighting you again.
Losing again.
Now out.
Like, fuck man.
Guys, you just don't understand.
Yeah.
Hey, it's on Skara.
It's not even on me.
Skara let him down.
Drew, Drew, Drew?
He's a very difficult character.
You guys are just jealous.
Well, they made new fan art for us.
That one is pretty good.
This is pretty cool too.
Damn.
These guys are crazy.
They retweeted it.
There's another one.
I have to find it.
There's new Fanheart?
Yeah, this one's really cool too.
Oh, they retweeted it already.
Oh, the one where we were wearing the Jaguar hats.
Yeah!
If I had more time, I wanted to make one of those...
Have you guys seen that LeBron James scream if you love...
I want to do that.
Scream if you love Team Brawl Pro.
When he points up, that's the Jack Jesus throw.
You know what I mean?
When he punches his teammate, those are the alley kicks.
Just boom, boom, boom.
I wanted to make it, but I didn't have time.
It would have been so fucking good.
I'm not uploading tomorrow because this is too much stress.
You're taking your first day off in two years.
Oh my god.
All it took was techin' A.
Finally!
I took a day off the first LAMP too, like afterwards.
Oh my god.
Oh dude.
Why did they just tune into him getting smoked?
Yeah.
Oh man, if you do make it, the scream for Scream if you love Team Brawl Pro is Doki.
Yeah!
That's the one.
That's my shit, bro.
We've been added.
It's time to play.
It's time?
But what about the other loser bracket?
Let's fucking get it.
Oh!
Okay, we gotta wait for the lobby.
Alright guys, it's almost time.
Guys, today I'm gonna learn...
Will Super be featured in the Brawl Pro edit?
We could do something about cutting him.
Cutting Super?
I don't know.
Did you see when Super was trying to help the ops?
He was helping SK.
Just like...
No, really?
You know like his moments?
I told him he's uninvited to the EVO party if he's the reason.
That's insane.
No, during his moments, just like...
Like, crop my picture and put it on his face.
Yeah, just everywhere you go.
Yeah.
That's insane, dude.
He's not going to dinner with us.
Fuck that.
That's crazy.
Yeah, we saw him.
There's VODs.
He was training SK.
I was like, how dare you?
But then it didn't actually end up mattering.
Yeah, cause...
You know, that SK might come in and fight us.
If we lose to Toad.
Oh shit.
Yeah, if we lose to Toad and they win.
Alright, he's uninvited.
Yeah, Fia and KFM are fighting.
So if Fia wins, then I have to fight SK.
What is exclamation mark snack?
Do I get one?
Is that the snack box?
I don't know.
I can't...
I mean...
I got one for free.
Yeah.
I don't even know the prizes for this one.
Honestly, other than the top two, I don't know.
I don't...
Like, what do we get for third?
A controller?
I think a controller.
I'm pretty sure.
Guys, I'm ready to get my ass kicked.
Guys.
I'm ready to be shown that...
I'm ready, I'm ready to fucking be on the floor.
Try to get one round.
Goal, guys.
Our goal today is to get one round off of SK.
That's the dream right there.
Wait, can I get that?
Wait, what do you text?
Alright.
Oh, they're texting something for a prize.
We're just waiting for a lobby right now.
Chat.
I only kick ease.
If I can get to him.
If I can fucking reach him.
He's so fucking fast.
I don't even know if I can reach him in time.
Don't think, feel, true, true.
That was my issue.
I kept thinking.
Like, when I win...
Don't think I win every game.
It's actually crazy.
I just need to fucking...
Stop.
I need...
Like, no thoughts.
Head empty.
That's how I win my games.
I literally...
How I won.
No brain.
Only grab.
True.
I just need to do that.
Oh.
There's the lobby code.
Alright guys.
I will hide my screen.
Because they're doing that thing where there's a password.
So you can't complain that I leaked.
Ummm.
Okay.
It's...
It's 5 4 3 4.
Guys.
If you wanna join the lobby.
That is the code.
So true.
I'm in.
I'm ready to get destroyed.
Kony just showed it.
Oh my god.
If Kony just showed it.
What's the point?
He already showed it.
What the fuck is the point?
Thanks Kony.
Alright.
Ohhhhh.
AHHHHHHHH.
Is everybody in?
2 4 2 3.
Oh wait.
We don't even have like majority of players in here.
Ah.
Ahhhhh.
Wait.
That's not 5 4 3.
They changed it guys.
They changed the passcode last minute.
It was 5 4 3 4.
When I was putting the password in guys.
They just changed it last second chat.
You just didn't see it.
Cause my screen was hidden.
Hahahaha.
It was such a fast password change.
Cause they're like.
Oh my god.
Kony leaked the password.
So then they changed it guys.
They changed it.
Before we could.
You know.
Before I could tell you guys the new password.
I would never.
How dare you guys think I would lie.
Doki would never do that to you.
Doki is the way of life.
The first commandment in the Doki lore.
Is thou shalt not lie.
And by that I mean.
You guys shouldn't lie to me.
Hahahaha.
Alright.
Here we go again.
AHHHHHHHH.
Let's go.
Let's get it fellows.
Here we go.
They said don't start.
Oh.
Okay.
It's okay guys.
I'm like the appetizer.
Before the main meal.
Hahahaha.
Uhhhh.
Let's go.
It's okay.
Kony can watch me and just be like.
Okay I should not do that.
No I'll be inspired.
More kicks.
Lots of kicks.
I'll be James Chen.
The Chen destroyer.
True.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
You're right our coach is in the interview.
He's not here to give us tips.
He's too busy in an interview.
Hahahaha.
Oh my god coach.
Wait what the fuck.
This guy is labbing against me.
Hold on.
Get this guy.
Hahahaha.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
The coaches aren't even here.
To coach us.
What do I do?
Hahahaha.
Stop hitting join.
Never.
I'm gonna join forever.
It's not my fault.
I can't believe it.
You're doing an interview.
Stop.
I'm more important.
Hahahaha.
So how was the labbing going?
He like pulled up the replays I fought against him yesterday.
Hahahaha.
You should pull up the replays too.
I did before he did actually.
Hahahaha.
Alright.
Does anyone know where Yisam lives?
Can someone pull his plug?
Florida.
Hahahaha.
Don't talk Yisam.
This is a joke.
For legal reasons.
It's widely known.
For legal reasons, please don't go to Yisam's place.
No.
Hahahaha.
I just knew the right answer so I want a teacher to pick me.
It's okay.
But if suddenly there is a power outage in wherever Yisam lives in the district that he lives, we were not part of the problem.
Yeah.
Hahahaha.
Come on.
Are they still in the interview?
I guess they are.
For legal reasons, that was a joke.
And all I said was a power outage.
If God suddenly sent a power outage to Florida, then him losing was meant to be.
Hahahaha.
It was just meant to be.
True.
Hahahaha.
Jack Jesus, hear my prayers.
Have a rat chew the power cables.
Hahahaha.
Hear my prayers, Jack Jesus.
Send that rat in.
Amen.
Hahahaha.
Alright, sorry they pulled me in for an interview.
That's why I was gone.
What did you say about us?
Good things, right?
Uh, they didn't ask me anything about...
They just asked us some...
What?
They pulled you into an interview and didn't even ask about us?
I mean, they kind of did.
They kind of did.
J.J.M is bald.
We talked about that, by the way.
Just so you know, Sly.
Really?
Yeah, for two minutes.
The truth.
Yup.
They can't censor us.
Alright, guys.
Let's see if I can pull a round off of this man.
Let's go.
He went to last game, last round against SK.
Yeah, but I feel like SK actually fucking trained...
Hahahaha.
Oh my god, I forgot everything you taught me about ducking.
Mid-range?
Or down and back?
Guys, I forgot everything.
I forgot everything!
That's okay, no thoughts!
That's how it always works.
Until today.
Wow, he really wants to go to EVO.
This guy really wants to go.
Good try, good try.
Hahaha.
You guys will deny it for me, right?
Yeah, of course.
Oh my god.
He's doing the down 2-3.
What does that mean?
Nothing, don't listen to me.
He's very good.
It means he's very good.
Oh, that makes sense.
I can feel it right now.
Hahaha.
No, he's doing that thing.
Oh my god, please don't slide.
Hahaha.
He is the online law player.
We found him, he's real.
Oh my god.
ESAM fights like you owe him hair.
Hahaha.
That's pretty good.
Back 3, back 3.
Back 3, here we go, here we go!
Back 3!
Boom!
I did it!
It's over.
Alright, it's over.
End this game now, I won the round.
Just believe, just believe.
Oh no, he's doing that now.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right!
Fucking nerd.
Fucking nerd, he's not!
Nobody likes it!
Get his ass!
Leave!
Nobody!
Oh shit!
Oh no, he's doing that thing.
Oh no, no.
Oh, I like the idea.
Thank you.
I'm glad you do.
Oh shit.
Hey, I'm back on the side!
That's clean!
He's not dead, he's not dead.
He's not dead.
We need one more mix.
Oh, he's dead!
Oh my goodness.
You got it, you got it.
You can do this, you can do this, Doki.
It's not a fluke.
Are you sure?
I'm sure, I swear to god.
He took me back to the other side.
No, he knows!
Oh, he took me back to the side!
Thank god!
Let's fucking go, good shit!
Oh no, but...
Let's go, Ally.
No, he grabbed me!
Guys, I think he analyzed the situation.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
I took two rounds!
You can block that, right?
If you hold back.
Does the slide?
No, it's guaranteed if he's faster.
Oh, is it?
Alright, nevermind.
Guys...
Honestly, you played that extremely well.
Oh my god.
Honestly, it's embarrassing for him.
Because he didn't get a perfect...
Honestly, I think if you just hold down, you win.
Really?
I'm serious.
I'm gonna do that then.
That's all he's doing.
All I'm saying is it's very embarrassing that he let me win two rounds.
Doki, remember we talked about you can low parry that slide too?
We talked about that.
You can do that.
The down forward square?
No, no, just down forward is the low parry.
Oh, down forward, okay.
Down forward, not down forward.
I don't wanna confuse you.
Just hold down and you'll block it.
You almost beat him when he got so much free damage off that.
It was basically a free round.
Of course.
Dude, it's Pikachu!
Oh my god, it is!
Oh my god, Gary!
That's fine, it's still damage.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, he's actually adapting?
What is wrong with him?
A lot of things.
Who the fuck adapts in a fighting game?
What do we know?
I know!
Nice throw.
Does he duck?
Oh, he does duck now.
Duck lord.
Choo!
I'm scared!
Yeah, you should be.
Losing two rounds to a B2B?
Boom!
Go back to Smash Bros!
Close.
Oh shit.
I need to remember that he does...
Oh, he missed it.
Oh, okay.
Oh no, I wanted to rage art.
Oh, he hits me first.
Yeah!
Nice try.
It's a good shot.
Oh.
He ducked it.
Oh, what?
I'm a dragon.
What is that move?
Grab.
I've never seen it before in my life.
Oh, he gets that off?
If DSS was still hard to do, this man would be cooked right now.
Oh!
You know what?
I mean, like the fact that you even made him sweat, I felt it from his monitor.
You went last round.
Last round.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
It's just embarrassing that he lost the two rounds there.
He had to change his stride.
He's not that much better.
Oh, I left the session!
Oops, okay.
Unironically, yeah.
I accidentally left the session.
No!
Remember, Kony, if he ever does the spinny low on you, mash four.
Right.
Also, if you think he's gonna do it, it's hop kickable, you know?
Yup.
And back 4-2-1 is a high.
The third hit is a high, right, Kony?
Mm-hmm.
But I'm gonna have to wait.
This is the last time I got fucked up because I got countered.
And we watched how Chensor beat him.
He did like...
He did like dick jabs into a down back 3.
He did shit like that.
Yeah, dick jab him.
Hella.
He'll win.
Oh, I didn't mean to pick this skin.
Hold on.
I don't think you can...
You can go back to the menu after.
Nah, it's cool.
Guys, it doesn't matter!
The other team leaked it already!
All the other teams leaked the code!
One reg Supa for every round you take off East Town!
Thank you for the Akahaka Supa reg!
Thank you!
He should be embarrassed.
He literally... I was looking at the Discord.
He was in the Sajam Slam Discord from morning to night yesterday.
Fucking practicing.
It was actually crazy.
I was literally watching...
I was looking at the server and he was there just playing Tekken.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh, there you go.
See?
Went for the fucking stupid low.
Nice.
You got that shit.
That counter hit.
Oh, fuck.
Let's go Cody!
Nice.
Nice job.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Break his streak!
Oh my god.
He's a dunker.
What a counter hit, Cody.
Yeah, get the fuck up.
Nice.
Okay!
Oh, nice!
Hold back to get up.
Nice.
Wake up.
I'm like five seconds behind.
Yeah, I'm pretty behind too.
Nice.
Obviously he was left there.
Like obviously.
Oh, you got that.
I can only think about what's happening.
If I close my eyes I can see it.
Just close your eyes and think about it.
Just
close your eyes and think about it.
Oh.
Oh, what a hopkick!
I saw it!
It was cool!
It was fucking dope.
Oh my god.
If only I could see that live.
Oh!
Yeah.
When he does that low.
Yes, yes, yes, you're right.
Oh.
Free fucking time, man.
Back to get up.
That's free inhale.
Nope.
Yeah.
Fuck!
That's okay, that's okay.
Know what the fuck he's doing!
Way, way, way closer.
Yeah, definitely you have to play him a few times.
To get used to it, yeah.
Yeah.
Just like, even on hit, on block, just match forward once you see the move.
Right, yeah.
I'm not thinking fast enough.
Remember, Kony, after that grab, if he grabs you, just hold back to get up.
You got it.
Nice.
I mean, like, what a fucking move.
And he doesn't know how to get up right.
And he just fucking ducks.
Agent Kony Banks.
Oh, Kony!
Nice.
Nice kick!
What a hop kick!
Oh my fucking goodness.
That's the real counterplay to that.
Let's go.
Let's go, Kony!
Get my revenge!
Nice.
He's ducking hella.
Yeah, that wall.
Nice.
Does he get up correctly from shoulder?
He does not!
What's that make?
That's so low!
You're insane!
Fight!
Alright.
R1 start!
Nice!
That's such a good combo.
Coach, why didn't you teach me that combo?
I tried to.
You have trouble with it.
You can try hiding!
Oh my god!
He's got a giant swing at the wall!
Take him to the wall!
Oh my god!
It's just a red Pikmin.
He's not even a flower Pikmin.
Yeah.
After you're running 3, Kony, you can hop kick this guy.
And also, he's not ducking.
So you can do Shining Wizards now.
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
But again, if you hit him with a running 3 from long range, he's gonna do d2 every time.
Well, that's what he's doing.
Yeah, literally the only time he didn't do it was that final, final hit.
Every time you hit plus frames, he does d2.
My read is plus frames hop kick.
But, you know, up to you, of course.
Get ready for the next battle!
Stone Kony Steve Austin.
Oh my god, look at him go.
Oh!
One.
Yeah, I mean, just fucking, it's as simple as that, really.
Oh my god.
That's up to you to make the adjustment.
Clean.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, okay.
That means that he's willing to rage art another time.
Just keep that in mind.
Yes.
Yeah.
That means that he will kill himself later.
Get a rage art here.
Right.
Fuck.
Yeah, I forgot.
Yeah.
That was like shit.
I know.
What I said wouldn't have worked, actually.
Oh, really?
Let's go, baby.
That low always beats my power crush.
Let's go, Kony!
Come on, Kony.
Yes!
Look at him go, man.
Oh my god, nice jump kick!
Force that 50-50 in the corner.
Look, he's literally back to the corner.
What can he do?
Yes!
Oh, look at him.
Look at him.
Yes for your life!
Oh, he's scheming!
Stop fucking running.
Fight.
Kill him.
No!
My goodness!
Kill him!
Oh!
I saw it now.
Yeah, baby!
Nice, Kony!
One alley for the fans.
He's mad.
Oh!
What the fuck?
You are unreal.
That was insane!
I couldn't... Oh my god.
Guys, this is a real King play.
Oh!
Hey, baby!
It's okay.
It's alright.
Yeah.
Okay.
My read is next time you're even a little bit enraged, just mash it.
Fuck it.
Send it, dude.
Sure.
Yes, Kony.
Oh, I can't watch.
I'm so scared.
I'm closing my eyes.
Oh my god.
That's...
That swing is incredible.
That's fine.
Burned it easy.
There's no way.
My god!
Did he do it?
Yeah!
Fart folks!
A fag game!
Raid It's the Frog on...
Fuck Me String!
Over and over!
Get the fuck out of here!
Level 9 computer bullshit!
Raid It's the Frog on...
Dragon On?
Arcade Mode Last Fight Before Heihachi Bullshit!
I am better!
Oh my fucking god dude.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Holy shit man that was frustrating.
Speak your truth, Kony.
Yell it to the world!
Dude you are the gold for the adaptation man.
Holy shit.
I mean I've never seen something more beautiful in my life.
It's so hot.
Dude the last set that I lost was because of that thing you told me where I was getting counter hit.
If I just didn't get counter hit.
Yes.
I lost so much shit off that because I was trying too hard to implement it.
Fuck man.
Here we go.
You are actually crazy.
Namaste.
Let's fucking go slime dude.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking get it.
Go slime go.
We believe in you.
How hard was that?
How fast is your heart beating right now?
It's so frustrating.
Dragging all this is so frustrating bro.
I feel like you need a fucking drink after that.
I can't spectate.
Let's get it slime.
I'm gonna restream Kony.
It's not letting me in the lobby?
Okay.
Oh my god no it's Brian.
He's a dick punch man right?
Uh no.
He's the guy that goes dick dick dick dick dick.
Yeah he's a dick punch man.
And he sometimes goes cock.
Oh yeah.
Good shit.
Okay.
We wait for that.
Yeah.
We break it.
I forgot there was another move.
It's all good.
We're still up.
Radar happens.
That's just knowledge.
Slime recognize the wall splats.
You could have won after your back one wall splat.
Okay.
If the wall is on that side and your back one.
Just think about it.
Very close.
Oh shit.
Wow.
What a block.
That was a crazy block.
Send the rage art when he's about to win.
He's pressuring like that.
It will work.
Nice.
Eat him.
Big dude.
Good.
Nice slime.
Good shit.
What was the orbital fucking hit me there?
That's fine.
Remember he does let the fucking rage art rip.
And I think you should rip it too.
You gotta set the tone.
Oh.
Nice.
Insane.
That's crazy.
That palm.
That shit.
Yeah it was a whiff punish.
Good shit.
Nice.
Damn that does a lot.
Oh my god.
That was such a good combo.
Fuck me.
Nice.
Good shit.
Good punish.
Nice!
Should have done an easier low.
Hellsweep was really dumb there.
He just reacted.
I don't know why I Hellsweeped.
It's all good.
Let it go.
It's okay.
It's all crushed down.
Forward one.
Slime.
Crushed down.
Forward one.
It's okay.
That's okay.
Nice try.
Good try, dude.
Alright.
I'm gonna try a bit.
Honestly, last night BoxBox beat the fuck out of me.
Use what he got you with, though.
Use what he got you with.
Yeah.
You got it this time, dude.
He showed his cards, so now you know exactly his moves.
Until he starts attacking.
I'll be right back.
Sorry.
Who won in the last coaches?
Did BrawlPro won or did their coach won?
During round robins.
I think it's 1-1 between the two of them.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It's time.
Make it to the coaches match.
Bring us to the coaches match.
Let's try.
I believe in you, Matt.
I will try.
Don't throw up.
I will also try.
There's a lot of things I'm trying here.
Good shit.
Okay.
That's how we started back up.
Still have heat, too.
Nice.
Good shit.
That's a lot of damage.
He got uprun.
Good shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna see this in... Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna see this in five seconds.
Whoa!
I saw it, too!
Round two.
Oh, we gotta launch those four two-stars.
Yeah, I know that.
Nice, two.
Keep it going.
Nice.
Round three.
I cannot believe that's saved.
Fight.
What is this?
What is this match?
Kill the Jack.
Keep on jacking it!
Jack it so good.
Jack it harder.
Jack it real good.
I'll do a sheet.
And you were worried.
I gotta pull up my Tony notes.
I gotta pull them up right now.
Sorry, coach.
Are you going in?
Are you gonna death fit or are you gonna...
No, we'll let her rock.
You got it, dude.
It's winners.
We'll let her rock.
You try to ice me like fucking Goichi, man.
Dragon Ball FighterZ all over again.
What'd you go back?
He's on his Goichi shit, bro!
He wants the switch sides.
I can't.
That's crazy.
I'm gonna go back to the Okay.
Two more rounds.
Nice.
Okay, release.
That's fine.
Oh, no.
I took 30.
I'm not to do 90.
Jack, Jesus, no.
Oh, shit.
Bouncer Jack.
We break it.
Oh, my God.
He's desperate.
Isn't it crazy how this round started with a 30% combo and all the life is back and she's dead?
Oh, my God.
Has anyone noticed?
Someone called the funeral to ask you.
Flash.
Oh, this is...
That's some rope.
You should just stand still.
It's sad now.
He's getting foolish.
No way.
The FD signifier slayer.
The slayer.
The skull crusher.
The Bart Simpson.
It's your own fault.
Oh, my God.
Get her off the phone.
Oh.
The Sharks are hungry.
The Sharks.
Stop the party.
Let's go to the Eiffel Tower instead.
Wait, wait, wait.
Matt, please don't try the wall run, brother.
He wants to do what you did, coach.
No.
Okay.
Maybe we got it too cocky here.
A little too cute.
Look, Matt.
There's a reason why you're not the coach.
He's a bonehead.
I really am.
I'm a cut.
I'm a donate.
He's stuck.
Flew too close to the sun.
Oh.
He's swinging, man.
I like the idea.
Oh, that's true.
My chat was like, we're just giving the coaches time to review his notes, you know?
We need proper needs for reading time.
Alright, my bad.
Fuck you.
Alright.
Well done, dude.
Fucking anchor of the fucking team, man.
He's just betting.
Me and Koki with the water wings on in the kiddie pool, we're like, yay!
He did it!
Yippee!
Coach, coach, coach, coach!
Yeah.
Let's get it.
Get it, baby.
Let's get it, bro.
Let's get it, coach.
I love you, bro.
We love you.
Win or lose, we love you, brother.
That's all I needed to hear.
We love you win or lose, straight up.
Let's go, gamers.
What if he just doesn't pick Brian?
That would be freaky.
That would be a throw.
I'm gonna use the bathroom to help your back.
Get ready for the next battle.
Fight.
Oh!
What a comeback.
You're at one HP, by the way.
Just to be clear, you're at one HP.
You're fucking him, dude.
Round two.
Fight.
Yup.
It's clean.
Good shit.
Turn that shit back.
Okay.
It's all good.
Ugh.
Fight.
Caw!
Heheheheh!
He's a good job.
Oops.
Hey, it's okay, BrawlPro.
It's okay.
I said oh.
Just making it close for content.
Fight.
Caw!
Heheheheh!
Yeah, that's right.
Play that Tekken 8, dude.
Nice.
Yeah.
Driver's seat.
There you go, bro.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
You gotta step that.
Let's go, baby.
Nice job.
Good shit.
Yup.
We hold back here.
Boom.
Good shit.
He's so freaky.
Nice!
Five seconds behind, but nice!
Fight.
Caw!
I'm closing my eyes.
Nice, dog.
Okay.
That's alright.
Hey, that was close.
Okay.
Very close.
Very close, dude.
You can do it.
Just play your shit.
What advice can I give you?
Heheheheh!
Guys, you're so evenly matched.
Oh, that tone is extra sweaty.
Yeah, he got no wall there.
So, I feel like you back out.
Get ready for the next battle.
I love you, BroPro!
God, it would be so funny if you accidentally picked the wrong key.
Come on, BrotherBear.
This is easy.
It's actually honestly easy.
Yeah!
That's how we start the game!
Hands weren't on the controller yet!
Dick punch.
Okay!
That's a wall, right?
Jesus.
Wow, what a block.
Oh, that kills him here.
I mean, that was a good block.
That was a very good block.
Yeah.
Round two.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
It's okay, dude.
You got it.
Let's go, baby!
Nice.
What a ducker.
Good kick.
What a noob.
Going through floor?
Put him on the wall?
Yeah!
There's another area?
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
I've never seen this area before.
Good shit, dude.
Yeah!
Yes!
Oh my god.
What a crazy two hit.
Jesus.
That's how we start it back up.
Oh my god.
Nice!
Watch it.
The RDC.
Oh, okay.
For sure.
Oh my god.
Look at that break.
Somebody needs to talk to the coach.
Oh.
Get up, Freaky Brian.
Fine.
It's a little bit.
Yes!
Oh my goodness.
Let's go, dude!
Let's go!
Come on, baby!
Fight.
I'm gonna close my eyes.
Oh, he's him.
Wait, what the fuck?
He's doing magic tricks.
Oh my goodness.
Back at the wall you go.
What?
What the fuck?
What's wrong with that guy?
What the fucking bait?
Are you serious?
What a fucking bait!
What a bait!
What is that background?
He's a fucking beast, dude.
Back out if you have to.
That's our coach!
Good fucking shit, dude.
I'm just running it back.
He's backing out to switch stages each time.
But I mean, I'm cool with it.
Let's just make sure he doesn't pick.
Make sure he doesn't pick.
It has to say random.
You did it before.
You can do it again.
If it doesn't say random, call him out.
Disqualified.
You know you can fucking do it, man.
Get ready for the next battle.
Let's get it.
I love you.
You got this.
Round one.
Fight!
Oh my god.
He swapped costumes.
He's serious.
Oh, he brought a gun?
Oh, he
brought a gun?
Nice.
So smooth.
You're faster!
Jesus.
Let's go, dude.
Yes!
Go, coach!
Pressure!
Fuck him up!
You're better.
Straight up better.
You're a fucking better player.
He's scared of you.
He is scared shitless.
Make him depressed!
And who wouldn't be?
Who wouldn't be scared?
I'd be pretty scared.
I'd be so scared.
Smoke and mirrors, baby.
Let's go.
Smoke and mirrors.
That's all it is, dude.
Let's close it out.
Be solid.
You fucking got it.
Solid play.
You gotta bounce here.
Round three.
Fight.
Go!
That bounce!
That's the stage you wanted.
You wanted to switch stages.
You asked for this!
You wanted this!
Oh, shit.
We might have smoked too soon.
Stop kicking!
What?
Did he dunk it?
I think he sidesteps.
Please be wall.
Oh my god, is it wall?
Is it wall?
No.
Oh my fuck.
Let's go!
You are my yordle!
He's gone!
He's going to Evo!
Oh god!
The good times!
Oh my god!
He's strong for me!
You might have a smack, but we have pro-pros!
Once again, team bro-pro.
Second gun!
The whore!
I fucking love this guy.
How does he do it every time?
Every time he does it.
How?
How does he do it every time?
Oh my god!
I'm suffering.
I didn't think it was possible for me to have this feeling since last slam.
It's all over again.
Team two trips, baby!
Team two trips!
You might have E-sum.
Put us in second.
I don't fucking care.
You might have E-sum, but you can't even beat our coach!
They have to win two sets now.
If they give it to us, anybody has to win two sets.
We fucking got it.
Yeah!
I do not care.
Play your losers, come back.
Who the fuck cares?
That was Tekken.
Why do you want to fight me again, Boxbox?
No, dude.
I might fight you later.
I can't.
He's about to adapt.
Oh my god.
What a thrill.
I'm done.
He's so fucking good, dude.
That was insane.
Good shit, everybody.
I'm shaking, man.
Everybody here.
Good shit.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Fucking wow.
I'm sweating.
I had to close my eyes during some of those moments.
That was so fucking scary.
By definition, too hard to watch.
It's so tense.
Now imagine being the one that had to play that.
Dude, it happened to me.
And again, we are the GOATS once more.
We are so fucking awesome.
BrawlPro, how did you feel?
How did you feel, BrawlPro?
What do you mean?
It feels good.
I'm shaking the whole time.
I'm having like a seizure the whole time.
You're fucking different, bro.
You're different.
Seriously.
He was so scared at the end.
You had him backing up, dude.
Yeah, the pressure fucking...
You changed the tide.
You really did.
You could see it.
You saw it in the game.
He was just anxious.
The Coliseum, it felt like it was the opposite.
It was the opposite.
He should not have changed.
You could tell the momentum shifted.
Oh my god.
Look at this tweet somebody made.
I don't know what happened anymore.
I seriously don't fucking care.
What a clutch, man.
Oh, hold on.
Bro, we gotta tweet to retweet.
Hold on.
I gotta retweet this.
I gotta farm my content recall.
Mr. Two Trips.
I go to Evo two times.
Send me again, man.
Two Spirit Plays.
Yeah.
I want the big seat on the plane.
I wanna ride with the pilot.
Put me in the cockpit, bro.
Give me the wings.
We did it for Doki Bird.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We did it for Doki.
We are all getting dinner.
Imagine Super how he's feeling right now.
But it didn't matter.
He's done with you.
He does get to come to dinner because it didn't matter.
We got to two anyway.
My rule was if he didn't, then he's uninvited.
Wait.
With me, you guys got a better record.
Because you have to go to loser bracket because last time.
But we're straight up into the winner bracket.
Yeah, we're better.
Yeah.
We have first or second guarantee.
We literally brain off.
I'm playing Pikmin.
Bye.
Pikmin time.
I've been playing four.
That game is so good.
It's very good.
That was my second favorite game of last year.
That game is so fucking good.
Out of all the Pikmins, which one did you like the most?
I like one I think.
One or four.
Because one is super...
I didn't like two because I didn't like the cave system.
Wasn't two the one with the water enemy thing?
Yeah, that's the one.
That's the one.
What are you playing for right now?
Yeah.
I was like, hmmm, should I play all of them?
Because everyone is talking about four.
And I tried one and the age got to me.
So I was like, fuck it, I'm just going to try four.
But once I played a modern version of Pikmin that was made for modern audiences, I fell in love.
I'm like, this is highly fucking good.
It might be my favorite game franchise.
It's so goddamn good, dude.
Yeah, I became a Pikmin fan.
And I am a fan of you because you fucking are crazy today, dude.
Holy shit, you are nasty.
I just want to say that.
You are impossible because you won, dude.
That's the only way this was possible, dude.
And I didn't mash while standing for one time, bro.
I didn't even do the right thing.
You had to adapt to a guy who beat you twice and you did.
Yeah, you did it.
Shit was stressful.
I didn't want to be the reason we didn't make it, bro.
I was just anxious.
We're all the reason we made it.
Without all of us, we would not have had that buy.
We wouldn't have had the buy.
We would have had this game.
We all deserve it.
Good shit, everybody.
Oh my god.
I like this coffee.
I'm so proud of you guys, man.
Seriously.
I'm so glad we're back, dude.
Could you imagine the timeline when we were on different teams?
I wouldn't have cared.
It would not have been the same vibes.
I told you guys this.
When I entered this one, they said we probably wouldn't be together.
And I was like, alright, I'm not really going to try.
But, dude, I fucking cared.
I'm 100% the same.
If I had any different teammates, like a different team, I would have been like, yeah, okay, Tekken.
I'll try, but who cares?
But now it's not the same.
And it really meant something.
And now Doki is here to fucking experience it.
Honestly, yeah.
I think if I was in any other team, I wouldn't be as hyped.
Doki, you fit right in.
Seriously, unironically.
We could have gotten somebody that didn't vibe.
You're in the family.
Oh my god.
I'm in the family.
The vibes fucking are insane.
Honestly, yeah.
All the fans are like, oh my god, team Brawl pros.
I love watching the content, the comms and everything.
Yeah, because we're just gamers.
Yeah, we're just vibing.
At the end of the day, we're just gamers.
All these other teams are like sweating and analyzing and trying hard.
Bro, it's vibes.
It's vibes over here, bro.
E-Sam doing his damn thing.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So last two rounds to a VTuber?
Like, what the fuck is...
Unironically true.
I know you're joking.
But like, unironically, that's true.
From a person that has 30 in defense?
Like, what's wrong?
I got 58 same Zs.
Holy fuck, I hate defense.
We all shared our stats, bro.
We all shared our stats.
I'm showing my stream now.
I got 54 defense.
I have 54, yeah.
I have no defense.
I was like, how do you have 30?
All offense.
We all shared our shit.
I showed my chat mod here like, how did you get to red with 30 defense?
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm that fucking... I'm that dude.
I don't know what to tell you.
I just got there.
I punch.
I kick.
Yeah, you fight.
$70 just to not play the game?
Get out of here.
That's what I'm saying, man.
We fighting this motherfucker.
Take your sensitive ass back to Street Fighter.
Wow, what a fucking dopamine rush.
They do damage, bro.
What's going on?
Something about like they're fighting on...
I don't fucking care.
Yeah, I'm watching CJ.
Bro, bro, bro.
Dude, the fact that you keep getting put in these situations...
He just keeps doing it.
Literally, it's remarkable.
Like, you're due for a loss.
It's unbelievable.
Crazy.
And they studied you, too.
And you still beat their ass.
I'm gonna enter online tourneys now because that pressure is nothing like this pressure.
Seriously, man.
This is the second time you've done it.
You're getting used to it.
Yeah, that's like free content now.
Let me just enter those.
Win or lose.
It's nothing like this.
There's no pressure, bro.
You got it.
It's like I don't even think like EVO would be as much pressure because the thing is, with this, there's an expectation to win.
I don't expect to win EVO, right?
But like here, we could fucking win.
That's what we fucking did.
Well...
To be fair, first or second, we know the fans will remember us only.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the last time.
The fans will remember us.
They'll remember us.
We can rewrite history.
Alright, don't tell me I gotta fight Amaz though because we won't go second.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Oh, SK got a round off.
Logan.
Oh my god.
SK got to 10-year-old?
Alright, fellas.
I'm gonna def him for a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Talk your shit.
I am so sweaty right now.
The AC is on full blast.
I know, right?
My temperature increased.
Yeah.
I feel it.
My bloodstream.
I gotta go turn that up.
Make the temperature lower.
Holy shit.
I could feel the sweat coming from both coaches.
Yeah.
You know Oli, right?
He came in my chat.
He was like, I just asked him, hey, are you going to EVO?
Because I know he snipes you all the time.
You guys are like buddy, buddy, whatever.
Fuck, I don't really know lore, but whatever.
And obviously, I already have a ticket.
So I said, hey, you're going to EVO?
He said no.
So I said, hey, if we win, or get top two, I give you mine.
You're gonna see he's going to EVO.
If his parents let him, he's 19.
Alright, well, that's also, I mean, like, I was not told this information.
Dude, he's in, well, I mean, Chicago's a big place.
He's in Chicago.
He can't go to Combo Breaker because his parents.
So I don't fucking know.
I don't know the lore.
Maybe they've talked it out.
I don't know.
If he's allowed to, I'll, I mean, I'll, you know, I'll give him my ticket.
If Sajam allows it, of course, you know, there's, there's quote unquote...
We'll demand for it.
We'll fight for you.
I do want to, I want to send, I want to send him to EVO.
Fuck it.
Because what else am I going to do with my ticket?
Holy shit.
This tournament has been so fucking hype, though.
Oh my god.
I swear, I've never been this nervous before.
And I'm not even playing some of these games.
It's like crazy.
It's actually crazy, though, guys.
I can't believe it.
We made it to the finals.
That's fucking nice.
We made it to the fucking finals, guys.
That's insane.
I did not expect it.
I felt like I had like the least experience out of everybody here.
And then I get to be in the finals.
Yeah!
I was the moral support.
Yeah.
I'm happy.
I like specifically requested BrawlPro2 to be my coach.
So I'm really happy that like I decided to play King.
You know, I don't know.
I don't even know how we got into me becoming a King player.
But like...
The fact that like I... I...
I just randomly decided King would be my character to play in this tournament.
And then because of that, I specifically requested BrawlPro for for like my coach because I was like, oh, he's a King player.
That would make sense.
Yeah!
And then it's Destiny!
It was!
Wait, so we have a hell of a time to chill now.
Yeah.
They gotta do KFM versus PDX.
Then whoever wins that fights Tone.
Then they fight us.
Yeah, yeah.
So we have to wait for two games.
Alright.
I'm just chilling, hanging out.
I'm mad chilling.
I'm gonna watch that Box box match and see how much I smoked him.
Ego boost myself.
Yeah.
I was so scared of him though.
Like he's so solid now.
He got so much better.
Oh my god.
It's actually crazy.
Yeah and he requested me too.
Apparently BrawlPro like requested from me as well because I was fucking around on King.
And it's just...
It's just crazy.
I'm really happy I got this team.
And happy that... because they were there for the first day jam slam.
They all got together.
And I was like the plus one.
And I'm just really happy to be able to meet these guys.
It's been such cool vibes!
I haven't grinded this hard in a game in a long time.
Like last night I was just playing rank and I was so toxic too.
Because I was just like, I wanna be in Shinryuu!
I think the reason why people... even though I'm in red rank and getting sort of demolished.
Is also because I feel like they actually analyze how I play.
And then I'm just like... I go rank.
I do allocate.
I think that is like my biggest weakness.
I don't adapt.
Everybody else is adapting.
And I'm just like...
Ali kick.
Good old... but then what do I do?
What do I do when they learn the... when they analyze?
What do I do?
And that's when I get absolutely demolished.
I'm actually surprised I still took two rounds off Esam.
And then he adapted.
And then I don't adapt.
I just go unga bunga.
But what if it works again?
I was like okay but what if this works again and he doesn't adapt?
And I was just like oh okay.
Wow this guy actually knows what he's doing.
And it worked.
I don't know.
Yeah.
What has happened to your golf?
Dude.
It was just... I think like... it says how many hours I have in this game.
How many... well to be fair, a lot of it is just buffer where we're waiting.
But it says here how many hours I have, right?
Yeah, 53 hours.
In like 53 hours, I...
I got like... well I wanna say like...
50... less than 50 hours because we've spent a lot on just waiting.
So I think like maybe like 50 hours or less to Red Rank.
I feel like that's really good in general.
And like for my very first...
For my very first...
45?
Yeah, maybe 45.
I'd say 45 hours not counting like all the waiting and the practice...
and just the practice range and the crashes.
I feel like that's really good for a new player.
Anyway, that's my ego boost today.
The fact that I got to this rank with like 50 hours...
I feel like I improved a lot.
And like I basically gate kept so many actual fighting game players too.
Because of the bullshit I do.
Because I know there's like so many people that are like actual hardcore grind fighting games.
And like they're like hard-scoring.
And they're like like stuck in like lower elos.
Like that fucking King player I bumped into that made it to purple rank.
And it took him like one and a half months.
And I'm like that's sad.
I'm sorry if you guys...
I'm not talking about you guys chat.
Of course it's not you guys.
But the ones that had like TTB in their names.
And they have the streaming tag.
And then I like looked at their stream.
And I just see like just made it to purple rank.
And I like looked at a one and a half months ago.
They were hard stuck red for one and a half months.
And I'm like that's so sad.
I'm literally like two ranks away from that.
From purple.
But not you guys.
I'm not talking about you guys.
I'm talking about one random purple king I saw.
Yesterday.
They're just like me.
But I'm so happy.
We made it to the grand finals.
We're currently waiting.
Let me put the text out.
I'll put a text out.
So people would know.
We are...
We made it to finals.
Waiting for our game.
Right now.
Okay.
I'll put that text up.
So people will know.
Yeah.
So people will know we're just waiting.
We made it to finals.
The grand finals.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're right.
Grand finals.
We made it to grand...
Finals.
There you go.
So people will know.
So people will know...
I should put it in the middle.
That makes more sense.
Actually.
Boom.
Wait.
Let me format it better too.
Yeah.
There you go.
Yay.
I'm so happy.
We made it.
I will be your new fighting game Oshii.
As I never touch Tekken after this.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll touch Tekken until I make it to purple rank.
Just to flex a little.
And then never touch it again.
Make it to purple rank.
Just to be like...
It's sad that you guys can't be in this rank.
No.
Please continue.
Okay.
If Sajam invites me to another Sajam Slam, I'll 100% say yes.
Or for any fighting game.
If Sajam invites me to any fighting game Slam, I'll participate.
I'll say yes 100%.
Peek purple and then start flexing?
I should.
I should just peek purple.
And be like...
Imagine not being purple.
He said it might be...
Oh, I never played...
Well, like I said, I never played any fighting game before.
So like...
Like...
I never played Street Fighter before.
Well, that's a lie.
I played...
Like, you know the arcade machines?
With the Street Fighter?
With the Street Fighter with Marvel characters?
I would go...
I went to the arcade and I just button mashed for that.
So like that was my...
But I was like super young too.
But if Sajam invites me to the Street Fighter...
The Street Fighter Sajam Slam, I'll say yes.
I mean, I'll message him and be like, I'm totally down to joining in.
But please put me in newbies.
And give me actual newbies.
I wanna be the next E-Sam.
Make me the next E-Sam.
I wanna know what it feels like.
Hahaha.
Wishful thinking.
Uh-huh.
Uh...
No, I'm still a newbie.
You can't say that I'm not a newbie anymore.
I still don't know how to block.
Haha.
Wait, that's not fair.
Connor was supposed to...
Connor was supposed to be in the Sajam Slam and he was in the last Sajam Slam and he was categorized as a newbie.
I'm a newbie.
It's not fair.
I should be like the next Connor.
He was categorized as a newbie even though he couldn't commit.
It's not fair.
I should be a newbie because my blocking stats are still like the newbie tier.
My attack might be red, but my block is definitely like beginner or first down or some shit.
My block is definitely in first down.
True.
Yeah, so like... I am a newbie.
I am a newbie, guys.
It's not fair.
Look, it's not fair.
This is my first fighting game.
I should still be in like the last seed.
Or was it first seed?
What is it called?
The last seed?
Yeah, I think I learned really fast.
I'm really happy that I learned so fucking fast though.
Who's winning at the moment, guys?
You guys know who's winning at the moment?
Oh, Team Phi.
Team Phi.
Oh, but then they have like Roy.
Roy is apparently really good too.
So... Oh my god.
It's Dragon Ball.
Wait.
Roy is getting his...
Roy is... Yeah, Roy has to win that because Roy is definitely not... does not belong in that seed.
Roy definitely doesn't belong in the seed.
It's okay, guys.
I will represent the VTubers.
I will represent the VTubers in the finals.
It's okay.
I'm so excited.
Also the rare Zaxxedon because we haven't had a chance to actually talk together for a while guys.
Because like last week or like this week if you want to say Sunday is the start of the new week or the end of the week.
It was like my technically it was my chill week where I like basically play Tekken.
So it's nice to be able to finally like actually talk to you guys and everything.
But oh my god what an eventful week even though like it was technically chill week.
Being able to participate in SageM Slam and like having SageM invite me to participate.
I'm so happy that he invited me to participate.
Because like I honestly I had no expectations I guess about it.
Like I was just like oh I'm so bad at fighting.
I'm so bad at fighting games.
I'm gonna drag my team down.
I was so scared.
Then it like like being in the team got me super motivated to like get better and improve and stuff.
And being able to just like playing fighting games for real for the first time and actually learning combos was really fun.
It was really fun.
I think it wasn't with any other team.
I wouldn't feel as passionate as I did.
So I'm just happy I got included.
Yeah.
I think if I wasn't so nervous when I was playing against Goomy I think I could have won that.
I was so nervous.
I was cause like I was thinking.
I need to remember to stop thinking.
Cause that's what got me here.
Cause I got all the punishes correct.
I got all the blocks correct.
But I did nothing afterwards.
I forgot how to kill afterwards.
Yeah, Determined Nerds definitely got me in that game.
But we still clutch.
Guys, but if I didn't, if I won that game.
We would not have got.
We wouldn't have got.
Our fucking insane coach game though.
So I'm happy I lost.
So we got the sickest coach game ever.
With the fucking wall jump.
That shit was crazy.
Oh my god.
The coach plays though.
We would have missed out guys.
We would have 100% missed out on the fucking like jump.
Bro, the fucking wall jump was actually crazy.
Oh my god.
That was fun.
That was so fun.
I love.
I was looking at the.
I was actually.
I was looking at the tags.
The tag.
The birdseeder tag.
And I like posted it in our team chat.
But I love the.
Doki versus Esam.
Was closer.
The tag.
The tag versus.
The tag versus Asuka.
That shit was fucking brutal.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Great time.
Oh.
I had so much fun with my team in the end.
Uh...
Yeah!
Bro, it's like the...
I swear, the...
The Kony-King mirror...
was like the slowest King fight I've ever seen.
It's so...
It's like actually...
It's like the two Kings just fucking thinking about what to do.
It's so slow!
I was like, please!
I can't take it!
I can't take such slow King fights!
It was so intense!
It was literally rock, paper, scissors!
Yeah, I would never be that patient.
If a King made me wait that long, I...
I fucking...
You can have it.
You deserve it.
Like...
You deserve that matchup.
Yeah, it was a chess match.
It was, honestly.
Alright, yeah.
Roy won their fight.
I mean, it was obvious that Roy was gonna win that fight.
Not gonna lie.
It was so...
Like...
Roy is really good at...
Was that character the main character buff?
He literally has the main character buff.
But FD wins this.
Oh, wait!
FD might win this.
So it's Team Phi.
Uh...
Jin's buff is real.
Yeah, but how well are you gonna do against...
Tone's team?
I feel like Tone's team is definitely like...
I think it was like...
It has to be the major upset because Tone's team is actually...
It is so fucking good.
I feel like Tone's team has...
Like, Tone's team was supposed to be in the flatness.
Because none of us...
All of us was like...
Oh, yeah.
We're definitely gonna go to loser brackets after winning...
Winning that.
We're like...
Oh, yeah.
Definitely, we're not gonna win against Tone.
So the fact that we did...
Was definitely...
Has to be a huge upset for Tone.
I think...
Yeah, I was so surprised.
Yeah, their team is really fucking good.
So I feel like...
Like, Fee versus Tone...
I don't know.
Unless they didn't study Fee's team and just heavily studied our team...
I feel like Tone's team would win.
Yeah, it had to be a major upset.
Like, even our team was like...
Oh, yeah.
We're not gonna...
We're not gonna win.
We're gonna be in loser brackets though.
Yeah, they were the favorites.
No, 100%.
I feel that we're gonna play against ESAM again.
And ESAM will...
ESAM will adapt.
All right.
You guys wanna play some couple of games while we wait?
I mean...
We don't really...
All right.
Let's do some games with the goons.
All right, guys.
Boot up the Tekken.
Guys, it's time to boot up some Tekken.
Create session.
Beating up goon.
Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
Maybe not.
Meaning...
Beating up people.
There you go.
All right.
Beating up people.
Okay.
Connection 3 or better.
Any.
We're one and done-ing people, guys.
All right.
This is the...
Doing custom...
Doing customs until...
Maybe this is funny.
Doing customs until our game...
Our final...
Our grand final starts.
Okay.
Let's see.
Name...
Uh...
Beating up people.
Password will be one, zero, zero, zero.
Let's see.
Where's...
Advanced settings.
Passcode.
One.
There you go.
Nobody will know.
How would they know?
Alright.
Create.
Alright, I'm gonna watch- I'm gonna use the bathroom so you guys can like fight each other first.
I'll be right back.
Alright, let's go!
Alright, who's gonna win this?
The- the king player?
Or the- the fucking victor crutch?
Alright, if you don't win this, you better fucking win this with an alley kick or you're not a true king main.
You better end this with an alley kick.
Give us- give the people WHAT?!
Okay, that was sick though.
That was pretty sick.
Give the people what they want!
Where is my alley kick?!
Entertain us.
Okay, yeah, that was fucking sick.
The dunk though?
The dunk was pretty fucking sick, not gonna lie.
The dunk was pretty fucking
sick, not gonna lie.
The dunk was pretty fucking sick, not gonna lie.
Oh!
Okay, go.
Cass is going crazy?
Oh no.
This king- This king might be like me, 30 defense.
This king might be like me, 30 defense.
This could be a- This could be a- I should be a 30 defense king!
Oh, just Team Phi won?
I'm not surprised.
Hell yeah, the Alligators.
They're the 30 defense...
Oh, Team Phi got eliminated!
Oh!
Okay, so Team Phi got eliminated, so it's...
So I have to fight Logan.
If Kauai team wins.
Oh no!
KFM.
Sorry, not Phi.
God damn it!
I got confused!
Okay, Phi won, so it's SKC.
Wait, is Amaz... Amaz is on...
Which team is Amaz on?
There's so many names!
Okay, because I know they said they didn't...
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Because my team didn't want to fight Amaz.
Alright, nice.
You didn't even end it with an alley kick.
You're not a real king player.
Alright, let me in.
I'm ready.
Let me in.
Somebody let me in, because you leave now.
Kaz, don't make me kick you out.
Because I will do it.
Kaz... Oh wait, no.
You guys didn't fight me.
Wait, no.
I fought you, Kaz.
Leave!
I already fought you in members.
You think I don't remember?
I already fought you in members... and you lost anyway.
Losers have to leave.
If you lose, you leave.
It's the way of the law.
It's the way of the Tekken... Tekken lad.
Bro.
It's the public humiliation.
Wait, what did Sejam say about the Tekken?
Alright, here you go.
Nothing yet.
He said... I thought he said that Evo wants to send everyone no matter what.
Is that what he said?
Oh my god, it's me!
With those shoes?
I was trying to see what Tony was saying about me.
Who the fuck... what's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you?
You're banned from the Doki council.
So talented.
You're banned from the Doki council!
Dokis need to wear shoes!
Doki Prime declares that all Dokis need to wear shoes!
What's wrong with you?
I think he said he might send third placers to Evo.
What the fuck?
I said send us next year, but I mean I'm just kidding.
We're free?!
Exactly!
How dare you give this for free and not monetize it!
What's wrong with you Doki?!
This is it, you get the alley kick special.
I can't believe it.
This is why all the other Dokis don't like you.
Hell yeah.
That's fucking right.
Remember this!
That's fucking right and you get alley kicked.
Oh wait I did that wrong.
And you get alley kicked.
Goodbye.
Wait what?
Oh, a free registration to anyone who has entered.
So that's, I mean that's 200 bucks.
That's still really solid but I was like wait what?
You just get to go for free no matter what?
I was confused.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Leave.
Maddie.
Leave or I kick you.
Where is he?
Yeah we have zero wins.
Fucking good luck man.
I can't believe Brawl Pro plays like that.
And then PDX was like he's for real.
Like what do you mean?
Plays like what?
Let me know when.
Okay.
When?
I don't know we should watch the last one.
Let me know when the last one starts.
I'll play, I'll fight like three more people and then we're gonna see the final match.
Yeah.
I mean I'll still play my heart out but like...
Wait what?
I'm ready to play something.
Alright, King versus King.
Don't be slow.
I can't do this no more.
Alright we... I can't deal with slow King fights.
I really can't.
I'm too impatient for that.
Are you gonna play Thousand Year Door?
Okay.
That's in a week.
Nice.
Oh I told you that helped.
Like I had it on my chip.
Oh wait you actually... Oh my god.
No please.
Please.
Try it.
Remember we had that conversation.
Don't block.
Chat would you watch this?
No!
I said don't block.
What's wrong with you?
Fight.
No.
What's wrong with you?
Well there's your fucking answer.
Am I not your Oshii?
You can play it for yourself.
That's right.
This is what you get for blocking.
Why am I playing a fucking cat and goat and god of destruction dragon off in quick match?
I can't do that!
We'll play ranked man.
Real King players don't block.
What is wrong with you?
Where's your fucking 30 defense King?
Like what?
What's wrong?
Banish him!
Banish him from the King Council as well!
You block and you're still in Garyu rank?
Like bro that's embarrassing.
You should be like higher rank right now.
How am I higher rank than you when you actually know how to play this character?
Like that's so embarrassing.
That's all I'm saying.
I don't know.
Is this first day?
No, this does not seem like a first day King.
He can defense but no Shinryu?
Exactly.
Where the fuck is your Shinryu?
Alright, leave.
Leave!
Alright, so one of you guys has to let me in.
One of you guys has to let me in.
Guys!
What are you guys at?
Are you watching?
Oh no, I'm playing Clique match.
What's happening?
The tracking is insane.
Tony's watching I think.
Sorry, I only played Rink for two days.
Oh now he's fucking flexing.
Oh yeah, I played Rink for only one day.
Never lied.
I never lied.
Oh, ESAM versus SK is starting?
Okay, we'll beat up this bear.
What the fuck?
Are you actually new?
We'll find out.
Alright.
Oh, he doesn't know how to skip cutscenes.
Guys, you can tell I fixed my PC.
So nobody can complain anymore.
I had to underclock my PC hard.
I fixed it though.
The solution?
That's not fixing.
It is!
Nobody noticed!
People were like, oh my god, she's on her new PC.
And I was like, yeah.
But now I had to confess.
Because like, I can't lie.
I had to confess to you guys.
Because I would never lie to you guys about it.
You know?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
You guys did not know shit.
Don't lie.
You guys did not know that I was using my old PC.
Because it looked good.
I was using my old PC.
It looked so good.
Okay, somebody has to fucking stop.
Nope.
This is why your environment is dying.
Bro.
This is why.
We're hunting you down.
You have nowhere to live.
What is he doing?
I ducked!
Can't be like Slime.
He lost every...
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
He's a good teammate.
Because I also lost every game today.
I also lost every game today.
I'm no better.
Slime is a great teammate.
Oh.
Oh, Slime.
You get your run back.
Maybe.
Now with Johnny.
Oh.
Wait, did I?
Nice.
No!
Not nice!
I failed!
Slime, catch me.
I'm sorry.
I got into a headspace that made me just wanted to roast everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Whatever.
Whenever I'm at a...
When I play Tekken, it's hard to stop.
Like, there's nobody safe.
Nobody safe from me.
That's why.
Nice.
Okay.
Just nobody is safe.
Everybody gets hurt.
Losing to a first...
You know that guy was not...
Actually a first on.
This guy fucking played before.
This is not their first fighting game.
This guy was not their first one.
Learned a combo first before.
I don't need to learn a combo!
I can get away with it.
Until I can't.
Okay.
If I don't know combos, it's because my coach didn't coach me hard enough.
Alright.
Alright!
Oh, you're right!
I know one combo!
Guys...
That's all I need to do.
I know one combo.
That's all I need.
I just need to know one.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, fucking Viktor crutch.
Using a crutch.
That's fucking... Wow!
That's not right!
What the fuck?
Okay, this is not fair.
He's literally blue ring.
That's not fair.
Stop!
I'm just right!
Bro!
Get away from me.
Oh, and you just got a roll?
Fucking bitch.
Yeah, you're a bitch.
Fuck you.
Get out.
Using a Viktor crutch.
Oh shit, I need to remember that he does that.
Oh my god!
I knew that was an easy low!
I'm learning.
Oh please, I'm not learning anymore.
I'm not learning anymore.
I stopped learning.
There's like a point where I just suddenly stopped learning because it's like too much, you know like pay a subscription To start learning more guys.
I used up all my data.
I use up my subscription data.
I Used up my subscription data.
It was like five gigabytes and all that five gigabytes was gone that Let me back in!
Let me back in!
The free sample has ended.
Your free monthly subscription has ended.
Okay, this is the last one.
It's very possible that we play Team PDX.
I mean, SK and ESM are tied.
They're tied?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, they're tied?
SK is punishing the slide.
How did she do it?
I mean, she's blocking it, then she's doing while standing 4.
She's blocking?
Popro, why didn't you teach me that?
I've literally tried.
For like 2 days straight.
This is why my defense is at 30.
It's a fear.
How is she blocking?
Just so we can say we...
Beat all the other teams, maybe.
I don't know.
Oh, that Rage Art is clean.
Oh, my team is all in ranked.
Trying to level up.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
I'm chillin'.
Quick match here.
I would love to not play Josh again.
I'll say that much.
I mean, you'd have to fight freaking Fairlight, dude.
Good.
Fuck it.
Yes.
I'll play FreakyPingway.
FreakyPingway?
If you launch his shoulder, man.
I mean...
I can't!
I'm on the wrong side!
SK is probably gonna take this, maybe.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if you guys are watching this.
I'm on the wrong side!
She's doing the matrix and stuff.
Alright.
After... Make this quick!
We need to watch the SK match!
Make this quick!
Okay.
I'm watching in the side.
Sorry.
I'm watching this on the side right now.
Okay.
If I lose, it's because I wasn't paying attention.
I need you to know that.
Okay?
It's not anything else.
I was not paying attention.
Alright.
Nice.
Now that's embarrassing for you.
Oh, please!
Why aren't you winning?
This is how I farm the reds.
You're a good example of how I farm all of you.
Thank you for demonstrating.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I did not mean that.
JK.
I meant it.
Yeah!
I meant it all.
I just didn't mean it.
Hurry.
Oh, shit.
Don't hurry.
Wait.
She didn't hit that.
Oh, no.
Guys, I'm not paying attention because I have to watch the game.
Ah!
There you go.
Ugh!
No, please.
I'm not paying attention.
Alright, Jake, I lost on purpose so I can watch the game.
Wait, SK won?
Okay, SK just won.
She just destroyed each team.
What?
She freaking destroyed him last round though.
Last round.
Oh, it's last round.
Alright guys, we're leaving to watch now.
We're gonna watch.
Where is... okay.
Let's see.
Watching...
To see who we fight.
In finals.
Okay.
Nice.
Replace.
Alright, sorry we couldn't play a lot of customs.
Wait, did SK win for her team?
Or did SK just...
Dude, I have to do one more.
I think she just won.
She won the first game.
She beat ESAM.
What's good fellas?
We back?
They're still gaming.
Yeah, yeah.
I want Fii to win so bad, bro.
I definitely could take FD, I think.
Yeah.
Okay.
What was...
What was SK's weakness?
Because I had no... I did not realize I was gonna be fighting SK.
If you have no idea, then you know what?
Just run your shit.
Okay, ally kick.
Maybe.
Yes.
Nope, ally kick it is.
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
Yes, sir.
Coach, what do I do?
You never prepared me for SK.
Um...
Hold on.
Let me watch some tapes.
Wait, Raidus is going crazy.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Does anyone have the...
Oh, never mind.
I got it.
The chart.
How did we do against Team Fii two days ago?
4-1.
It was me.
So we're way better off against them.
Yeah.
Wait, only Doki lost?
I lost to SK.
I got like one round off her.
I think we 3-2'd a different day.
Like we 3-2'd and then 4-1'd.
I see.
I think.
Mix.
No way.
She went for that giant mid and it worked.
That's sick.
She got a round off.
We went 3-2 day one against them, then 4-1.
Yeah.
I'm way more confident against them.
I mean, we can beat Tony, obviously.
But...
Tony's team is just crap.
Tony is just stressful.
I feel like...
But they do have to win two sets.
So...
I think it's because like their team all like analyzed us, but they didn't really analyze each other.
Sure.
I feel like...
It's possible.
Because I know a lot of them were hard grinding against our characters.
Wait, why is he D-Packing her?
Whoa!
Did he?
Yeah.
That's so toxic.
I didn't see it.
That's fucked up, man.
Maybe Raze just annoyed that you beat him.
He's taking out his anger somewhere else.
That's true.
He's like, I shouldn't be...
Dude, I was very disrespectful in my shit.
I feel bad.
I was so annoyed after we watched those tapes last night, dude.
Like...
I was like, dude, he's doing one thing.
Yeah.
You lost to the Heihachi gatekeeper.
Heihachi gatekeeper?
I'm about to fight Heihachi and Dragunov walks in front... wait.
He's a bot?
Dude, that's mad disrespectful to say about him.
I know, I know, but I was so fucking mad, dude.
Oh, man.
Oh my god, she's kinda...
She's going crazy.
She's kinda...
Oh, she's steady.
Are we sure we want to beat this team?
We blocked this.
Okay.
I'm way more confident against Cat than Reed.
It's because Cat kind of gets scrambled.
Scrambled against pressure.
Yeah, she gets really flustered against a lot of offense.
Remember the last time you saw her?
Oh, good break.
I fucked on her, not gonna lie.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh, no way.
No.
What if I tackle you back?
That's crazy.
Sheesh.
Obro's got his bowl out.
That's a really nice wig.
I know, right?
You can't even tell, bro.
Goes into the sideburns too.
That looks nice.
The technology is kinda crazy.
It's all that Chipotle money.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's got it out because he knows he's saving money now.
That horse hair.
What is that?
Horse hair?
That looks good.
Slime Truth.
I've had Slime Truth pinned all stream at the time.
That's the best fucking email I've ever seen in my life.
Dude, you had to watch it when he made that in real time.
That was the funniest thing ever.
Dude, the fucking Photoshop AI.
I asked it to make him bald and it delivered me so good.
Maybe AI isn't so bad, bro.
I literally was like, you know what?
This is a good application of the Slime.
We work with the machines.
Dude, Slime.
It's a utopia.
At first, you were like, make him bald and then they turned him into a stock image shrugging.
And he was still bald.
It was crazy.
Yeah, it was funny.
And then to fix it, you said, make his head bald.
Oh, and it fixed it.
I'm like, what the fuck is this?
It's an imperfect technology.
If it comes to specifically making Sejam bald, I support it.
Only for that.
Make his head bald.
It's so redundant, but it works.
Can we go further?
Yeah.
Come on, Cat.
If Cat wins this, they only need one more set.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's gonna send us.
Oh, no way.
She could have just...
Oh, he's dead.
That's it.
Dude.
Oh, no way.
No way she chose.
No way.
That's unfortunate.
She could have won that.
She's probably...
I mean, they're probably super stressed.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean, like they're the underdogs, you know?
Tone's team might be on tilt from what happened with...
Tone's on tilt?
Tone's on tilt 100%.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You can see it.
I did not expect this.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think your team is on tilt after what we fucking demolished them.
Demolished.
Demolished?
Demolished last day.
Yeah, yeah.
That's three to two.
Demolished.
Ah, it's a lot.
Shit.
Hey, I'll stay.
I'll call it how it is.
Rage Art?
Yeah.
That was the most obvious Rage Art.
Oh, that was a good one.
Dude, he just pops it.
Rage just lets it go.
Hey, if it worked, it worked, right?
And that gives us a set.
I mean, I let her rock too, you know?
Yeah.
No, I'm not saying there's anything wrong with it.
It's like...
It's great, especially with how much pressure Cat just keeps running up, but...
It's a good spot.
Yeah.
The harder you go in Tekken, the more it'll be like, plus frames, dash up, wait, you know, because you're afraid of the rage art.
Then the mind games start and it gets fucking scary.
Yeah.
Please, Fi, please.
I'm fucking repairing that.
Dude, that Chipotle unironically looks good.
Did you guys already use your free code?
Dude, I used my code.
I used my code for lunch today and I just saw a text message from my wife.
She was like, hey, I got you a Chipotle burrito.
It's on the stove.
We didn't even talk.
Like, she just, she just got it.
So now I got another one ready.
What the fuck?
That's lunch tomorrow.
Maybe Chipotle sponsored your wife.
No.
Oh, I love this stage.
Shit.
Nice.
The last round.
Lol.
Dude, the moment he didn't fucking take muscle buster, I was like, oh, it's over.
Did you hear?
Yeah.
No, it was an offense.
It's relentless.
There's gaps though.
Everything he's doing, except for that move, everything else he's doing, there's a gap.
Jeez.
Dick jab is your friend against ravenous.
Like that?
He's doing four, four.
You can back three him in between, or you can jab to float him.
What's four, four?
You can duck that.
Point it out when you see it.
I don't know what it is.
Okay, sure.
He did it on you a few times.
If I can back your hat.
There's that three string.
Yeah, see his one, two, one worked after because the third hit is that's a high.
It's plus if you block it.
She's fumbling now.
That was good.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah.
So the thing about Ray is you see he does like that double hammer down, right?
And it's plus and he kind of fucks on you.
Like he always does something that is not still.
Real afterwards.
Like he'll take an extra, extra long move.
So just dick jab after you see that honestly, and you fucking you beat him because he takes too many turns.
He's like, oh, I'm hella plus.
Let me do an even more slower move, but it's not airtight.
You know, that's my issue is I don't know how to take my turn back consistently against them.
It's like if I can't land the power, he's just oh my God.
Mix.
Oh my God.
He's just oh, dude.
We got a block that we can't let him win with that.
Stupid move.
It's literally all he's doing, man.
That's the most.
Rodulent drag I've ever seen.
Oh my God.
That's tight, though.
But that's crazy because that's what we talked about is like anytime I get hit while standing for and then I just forget like when I'm in game, I'm like, uh, yeah, minus on hit.
Yeah, I mean, if he again, if he notices you're doing the while setting for after he can counter plate, but is rated to doing that, you know?
No, not not at this point.
He's not gonna.
He's not a grand finals.
He's been getting away with it so long, you know?
Yeah, just match for if you just see the move at all, you know, block or hit block, you get a punish hit.
You probably get a punish.
Who does Josh have to play?
Did he beat this guy last time?
Josh Fairlight.
Yeah, Fairlight Strong.
This is in favor of Fee, I think.
I don't have the things.
So it'd be Fee Tony, which which is like they played earlier and then all and then Tony had sent him to losers.
Yeah, at the turn.
Oh, wait, how did we for one box box?
The slime slime beat Fairlight?
No, no, no.
That's kind of nasty.
Wait, then we did it for I beat Kat.
She beat I didn't be asking.
No, I didn't BSK.
Oh, you didn't know.
No, I only beat Logan.
Just straight up lies.
So get in a more.
Okay, because I know you beat fee.
He beat FD and I beat Kat link.
Oh, okay.
So we just three, three, two.
Might be three twos.
Slime can be Fairlight.
Is this slime paying attention?
So I'm even paying attention.
Slime has better be watching true.
He's watching more melee.
I respect it.
Is he actually okay?
I'm fine ranked.
All right.
Yeah, he's fighting a Xiao Yu right now.
Oh, yeah.
Don't don't worry about Xiao Yu.
The fucking character is stupid.
Oh, I know.
I hate that guy.
You might have to play Fairlight slime.
I mean, to be fair, FD box box is a mix up.
Their games are so close every time.
Right.
Oh, I see.
We don't know how it'll go.
Yeah.
I'm just you know what?
I'm just enjoying the matches.
I'm taking my break.
Holy fair.
Like guy is goofy with these combos.
Compose?
Snake?
Snake edge.
Jumping.
Catch the roll.
What is this shit?
These Raijin like strats are crazy.
I like the shit that I see working.
Oh, my God.
He just cooked this man.
The slime.
You gotta watch your roommate.
He cannot tell a lie.
A old honest Abe.
Doing very honest strings.
Mr. President.
Very honest strings indeed.
This guy definitely does not know bang.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Let him get up.
Oh, he did.
That's so nice of him just to beat him up again.
Okay.
Oh, no, he's about to.
He did the good pose.
All right.
I thought he was about to do something.
I had to turn the camera off.
What's the other pose, Kony?
Oh, you know the other one.
You've seen it.
I don't like that one.
The double L's is fine.
The other one is fine.
Is it over?
Wait.
Is it all over?
Or is it just one?
Not yet.
No.
There's still one.
He just won one round.
Yeah.
But that was a three-oh though.
No.
Yeah, that was a three-oh.
Yeah.
I don't think Josh knows Feng at all.
So it's probably gonna be a while.
Oh, I see.
Rune.
Okay.
But Slime, you can see the things that the Fairlight is doing.
And he's the same rank as you.
I mean...
Yeah.
...doable.
And Slime, you never do while running one plus two into bear stance into the grab.
You never...
Yeah.
I got into matchmaking to practice that, to get used to that because I realized it is not something I've been doing.
We got more...
I did it to that Chao Yu twice.
Got her.
And remember...
Got her ass.
Back one plus two.
Bear stance one plus two.
It's...
You can just throw it up.
I actually want Josh to win so bad.
I don't want to play him, but I can't...
I can't root against him here.
Yeah.
Of course.
I mean, I want Josh to win, bro.
Yeah.
I mean, I want Josh to lose, but you know...
He's a sweetheart.
I love the guy, but...
I just hope as many people come to EVO as possible.
Win or lose, whoever, you know.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
He's a sweetheart, dude.
Dude, when he first saw me in Slime's chat, he's like, oh, Slime, that's the dick writer.
Bro, bro.
I'm like, what?
I was like, that's my student brother.
What do you mean?
I got to hype him up.
Yeah.
He's...
He barks a lot, but it's zero bite.
That does not look like Brian.
This skin is disarming.
Like, that's a normal guy.
He looks like...
I think he was in the Gathering commercial in like the 90s where they're like, what's this about?
And they're like cool rad dudes.
I'll link it to you guys.
No.
He looks like that.
He looks like one of those guys.
That is such a specific reference.
He looks like a guy from a Mentos commercial.
Is that the one?
You're going to instantly get it.
I feel like I can already imagine the commercial based on what you're saying.
What?
Oh my God.
These guys are gaming.
They're just fucking punching each other.
Oh my God.
He looks like the guy from Streets of Rage.
Oh, Axel?
Kinda.
That's just a white shirt and jeans.
Who's he supposed to be?
Isn't he supposed to be someone?
Is he Leon?
Leon, but like Leon the weird.
Streetwear Leon.
90s Leon.
What the fuck is this commercial?
It's like a...
It's like an MTV spot actually for Magic the Gathering.
Dude, I'm going to keep it $100 with you.
I've never seen this.
This is insane.
Yeah.
I didn't know it either until I started watching Magic the Gathering YouTube, which I don't know if it's a game.
Pony Young confirmed?
I feel like Tony...
Slime, I have a question because you're as old as me.
Did you used to watch like MTV Spring Break and be like, hell yeah, that's going to be me someday.
No, I used to.
No, you know what?
I used to watch it.
I wanted to be so cool.
I watched it and I said, I hate this.
I wanted to go back to normal MTV.
Barely won by the way.
You didn't watch like Singled Out and were like, hell yeah.
No, I thought it was cringe.
Except my friend's sister who had a crush on, she liked Blink 182.
So we would watch MTV together.
She'd be like, oh my God.
Let's watch MTV.
TV Spring Break.
I'm like, yeah, of course.
I love that.
I used to watch that shit with like, you know, the big stage.
I was like, damn, one day I'm going to be a cool 21 year old on Spring Break.
And like, it just never happened.
And what happened?
You know what I mean?
I played Brawl and spit.
Yeah.
I think you went in the exact opposite direction.
I...
The hardest opposite direction you possibly could have.
Yeah.
Besides becoming Amish.
Wow.
Feze team is all streaming in discord.
It's so weird.
Oh, they're, they're hard, like coaching, like live coaching, maybe.
That's all I took it.
There is no delay.
I'll play against Freaky Bryan.
You hear nothing from brawl pro.
I hear crickets from him, dude.
Are you serious?
I don't want to.
Freaky Bryan.
He's too freaky bro.
Freaky!
I want freaky answers and I get nothing.
Freaky answers!
I wanna say so much but I don't wanna throw you off dude.
Play the Goosebumps theme bro.
If you jump that high you'll get a freaky launcher.
Just say it like that?
Yeah, send it man.
Freaky launcher!
Shit go extra high!
Wait, pay attention Matt.
What do you mean pay attention?
Dude, this is Freaky Eddy.
What do you mean?
Oh yeah, he's gonna pull an Eddy on you!
Yeah bro, we're talking freaks!
Like dude, you're gonna fight this shit bro.
None of us trained for this!
Sicko mode combos and stuff.
Damage.
Oh my god.
Eddy's freaky too man.
When he gets it on his hands...
If he feels a little freaky he goes with the two.
Eddy players be like, I wanna mix this up today.
Two!
How about a punch?
Oh my god, armor.
Let me use my hands for one second.
To the mid.
Bro, I love this stage.
I think if she does it, it goes low 7 billion times.
Is that real?
No, but does he know...
I was gonna say, does he have experience knowing that that's safe if she charges?
It's not just safe, it's plus.
It's unfair to her.
Oh, okay, shit.
Boom.
It's her turn.
I don't know why he did that.
If he wins this, then they...
Then we fight them, yeah.
This is gonna hurt so bad because like, EVO's on the line here.
So like, this guy...
This is what we were experiencing, right?
Yeah.
Now you're right.
I feel like...
I feel like T0ke's team didn't train for this team.
At all.
Bucks, bucks.
T0ke, I don't think you're wrong, man.
I think, seriously, people trained for us.
Yeah.
Because that happened last time too.
Yeah, because I did not expect T0ne's team to not do that well against V's team.
Yeah.
Because they knew all our shit.
I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Nice.
Dude, and BoxBox really wanted to win.
Yeah.
One more set, one more set.
For the boys of Rio.
Damn.
So maybe they just focused on us.
Yeah.
Do we know how to fight against V's team?
Like...
Well...
We won 3-2, which means it was a coach match.
Alright, bro, bro, you ready?
That's assuming I beat FD.
And last time that shit was literally one hit.
Yeah.
We'll see.
But I know the matchup better now.
In the end, the fans will remember us as first place winners.
We will rewrite history again.
Ugh.
Another silver medal, eh?
I can't take it.
You better be watching the farlight fight then.
I really actually should.
I'm not stupid fucking, uh...
Like, while standing for this.
Fake as shit, right?
He just did?
He just did it twice, right?
Bro, bro, coach!
I'm here.
I'm sorry, dude.
I'm sorry.
Coach, the one time I asked you a question...
Coach, is it real or is it not real?
Young man.
I asked you one question throughout the entire Sajam Slam and the first one and you're not here.
If FD's fire did it, it's not real, bro.
Oh my goodness.
Coach, do something.
Dude, they're posting ASCII art and I had to ban them.
Sorry.
Oh my goodness.
Wasn't it bald Mario smoking a cigarette?
No, it was just titties.
Keep it up.
Old stand-by's, honestly.
Classic.
Oh my god, what is that?
Crazy rage art.
What did he do, Matt?
He was doing the stupid down back three and then while standing four.
And you were like, that's minus five and he's taking his turn at the launch.
Right?
You remember?
Yes.
No, it wasn't because he still had his heat.
Oh, got you.
Also, Matt, he stopped doing it.
I haven't seen him do that shit one time yet.
He just did it twice.
That's not...
That right there, that's fake as fuck.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, down forward two if he hits you with that low.
But he is finishing that string sometimes, which he gets a free crouch throw after.
Dude, Pox, get me the fuck out of here.
I don't want to play.
Get me out.
Help.
He's too freaky.
Freaky Eddy is real.
Eddy is like that guy you find in Sekiro in the really small area with the claws.
Like the centipede guy.
That's how I feel when I watch him.
The guy you got to parry eight million times.
Yeah.
Oh, I hate that guy.
Oh my god, what a parry.
Oh my god.
Oh, did he miss?
Damn, dude.
Well, we're playing against Fii's team.
What a way to lose, man.
That sucks.
Damn, dude.
We gatekept.
We did what we said we were going to do.
We actually gatekept Toto the fuck again.
We gatekept.
Oh, Evo for E-Sam.
No, Evo for E-Sam.
Yo.
We actually gatekept.
We are the most toxic team I know in here.
That's what you get for smurfing.
Yeah, fucking E-Sam.
Yeah, that's what you get for wanting it so bad, dude.
Yeah.
Just wait.
Just let it come to your lap.
We have Jack Jesus.
Jack Jesus is the most valuable ore found in any mine ever.
It's Mithril.
Yeah, it's like...
I just watched that big robot get on the screen and I'm like, it's just going to be a good day.
He's so fun to watch.
That's true.
You like, you like look at, look away for one second and then 80% of the health is gone.
I'm considering bringing out the Kossack kicks.
BrawlPro.
Thoughts?
And once again, once again, follow here.
No, no, I'm done with you.
I'm done.
He any kicks with real kicks.
Bro, bro, bro.
If we lose, actually your fault.
Bro, do not Kossack kick, brother.
There it is.
Don't do it.
Do that move where you sit on your butt and then you swing your arms a lot.
That's what I was gonna do.
Oh my god, yes, there's more fan art.
Try that.
Oh my god, that fan art's sick.
I'm retweeting this one too.
There's a lot of good fan art, bro.
Wait, we got more fan art?
Yeah.
There's like four to the one.
Oh, new ones?
Oh shit.
Hold on, I gotta check them out.
Damn, these are sick, dude.
That's good, man.
Unironically pulling up.
What the?
That is crazy, bro.
Oh my god, nice.
You're in the limo, bro?
Bro, look at slime just fucking chilling up there on top of the limo.
They have the costumes we're using too.
Because I always use that color.
Wow, that's sick.
This is us pulling up to Evo.
We should rent a limo.
Wow.
I'm fucking down.
I'm currently on top of the world.
Alright, fellas, one more set.
Alright.
Perhaps two.
One more, perhaps two.
We're on top.
Let's just finish up.
Oh shit, they're about to do the interview.
Let's get them, coach.
Alright, yeah, coach.
Gas us up.
Tell them how we feel, bro.
Tell them how we feel.
Wait, how do I counter SK?
Where are my notes?
This fucking coach is...
I'm here, I'm here.
Where are my notes against SK?
He's more preoccupied with the interview, bro.
He's up here for the clout.
It's Hollywood.
Everyone says he's Hollywood now.
He switched off.
He thinks he's too good for us.
I get to be on SageM stream?
He let us go.
Come on now.
He's too Hollywood.
He's actually too Hollywood.
He said he'd give us notes and then he didn't.
It's true.
The video's real.
He's too Hollywood.
I knew something was up when he got all handsome.
I see that now.
That fame came got to his head.
He won two coaches matches and now he thinks he's better than us.
Hold on.
I will DM SK, ask her to throw.
Maybe it will help.
I mean, they're already going to EVO.
What do they care, right?
Yeah.
Hello, can you throw for God's sake?
It would be like the biggest character arc for me.
It would be so good.
Imagine the clips.
Say that we'll win trade.
Say we'll win trade.
Give Doki the win and I'll trade my FD win.
Tell to the world while all of us are streaming that we'll win trade.
Give Doki the win.
That will throw.
I swear, I cross my heart.
I hope to die.
I will literally I will play like shit.
Brain off moment.
We're doing business at the table.
We're running it twice.
All of this is for content, right?
Just think about the clips.
He fucking proposed showing it on stream.
I'm definitely going to hear this interview.
All I'm saying is that if I win against SK, just imagine the amount of views we're going to get for both of us.
Lobby's up.
Oh, alright.
Don't worry, we'll edit this out during post, guys.
They'll never know.
They'll never know there was match fixing.
I like how the passwords are so complicated.
But we're all showing it on stream.
I don't have the elements like BrawlPro.
I don't have a PNG to cover it.
Wait, is BrawlPro actually covering it?
No, no, he said I don't have the elements.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
I cannot cover it.
Me too.
We can't cover it, guys.
I don't have enough hard drive space to make a PNG.
Yeah.
I don't know how to open up PNG.
Oh my god, people are saying Tone actually looks depressed.
Bro.
No.
No, Tone.
You should have studied up other people, not just us.
It's funny, you think about like when you get really good at the game, you're like, oh, they don't like complain about like cheese or matchups or like they're like iron will.
And then you just watch high level people play each other and they're just like fucking dog shit.
Who plays like that?
Who fucking, who grabs there?
It's so funny.
You're like, they're just like us.
They're just like us.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, yeah, we're waiting for our coaches.
Oh, this is cute.
This is cute art.
It's...
Three kings.
Oh my God, guys.
It's time.
The finals!
We made it!
Doesn't matter what happens.
We made it, guys.
We made it to the finals.
And that's all that matters.
No matter what, chat, everybody will remember us.
We will.
If we don't win, we gaslight all the fans into thinking we won.
And that's it.
That's all that.
I thought they...
I thought this team won last time.
I actually just thought this team won last time.
So, like, the gaslighting worked.
We can do it again.
Because I'm a professional at this.
I...
Don't worry.
If we don't win, we won.
Guys, remember, no matter what, we won the finals.
Okay, guys?
Always remember that.
We won the finals.
It's forgotten.
Well, well, well, well, well, well, well.
I'm not that nervous, though.
Because, like, I know my place.
How does she do it?
Guys, I can't...
Guys, we did it!
We won the tournament!
Guys!
We did it!
Okay, let's practice that, chat.
We gotta practice.
Okay.
When we... Obviously, no matter what, when we win, how are you guys gonna react, guys?
Oh my god, guys!
We did it!
Yeah!
Yeah, we gotta practice our celebration.
Because we're gonna celebrate winning.
No matter what happens, chat.
We won?
No way!
Reaction practice.
Guys, I need you guys to be more hype.
I need you guys to rewrite history for me.
Chat.
How are you gonna rewrite history if you're not as hype?
Let's go!
We're just waiting.
We're waiting on...
our coaches to come back to us.
to us.
Um...
And...
And then we can start.
Yay!
That's all we need to do.
We just need to wait for our coaches to come back to us.
Yay!
Doki's tired.
Guys, it's been five hours.
We've been techening.
Whoa, we've been techening for five hours.
Alright, alright.
Yay!
When are we starting?
They're having some giveaways before they get started.
Oh, so they're still doing the giveaway stuff.
My chat's practicing on celebrating no matter what.
That's good.
Good community.
They're gonna... if we lose, they're gonna make sure everybody knows we won.
If we lose, we win.
If we win, we win.
It's literally impossible, so...
Let's just finish up.
Yeah!
I'm so happy.
I'm like, relaxed.
I'm not nervous at all anymore.
I'm just relaxed and chill.
Now.
I got what we wanted.
We made it so far.
So I'm not as... I'm not nervous anymore.
I'm just here to vibe with my team.
I'm just happy!
Yippee!
And a little eepy.
I am.
I said I'll...
She wants something.
I said she can have my Chipotle code.
What if she's like... what if she's manipulating you?
She's tricking you!
No.
I'm too smart for that.
Okay.
We gotta get a final answer soon.
We're gonna get an answer soon.
We can see it based on how she plays.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She gotta make it look real though.
Yeah, make it look real.
Like how I'll make my loss look real.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's gotta make it look real.
Like, if she starts beating shit out of me, then take that code back.
And the world will know she's a liar.
That she wouldn't match fixeress.
How could she?
What does heated tone say?
GG's I hate you.
Sorry tone, listen man.
Listen.
Yo, look at my chat Matt, if you see it.
I'm sure she'll stream open.
Ha!
Sorry, there was a copy pasta, bro.
Hold that tone.
I'll see you at EVA.
Do the giveaway faster.
Matt, your ass.
I didn't drop a single game.
Where is he typing this?
He's already rewriting history.
Do I read your chat?
He said, Matt, your ass.
Bro pro, you're carried.
Damn.
Can your lips say that to you?
It's okay.
I just, I can't hear you all the way down there at third.
I hope you have to edit for six days.
Nope, I am taking a break.
I...
Where's the lobby?
Whose lobby is it?
It's in stage one.
Phoebe posted it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, he posted that a while ago.
I'm not in there yet.
Yeah, I didn't ready up.
Don't worry, coach.
I'm keeping them hostage for you.
Let's get it, team.
If you win and it seems obvious, I will throw.
But if it seems like... No!
What the fuck?
Shut up, shut up, shut up.
Shit.
We got second last time, bro.
I'm not trying to lose again.
We're trying to get some match fixing going on here.
For the content.
Alright, I'm readied up.
I saw brah pro and I'm fucking in.
Yeah, I'm in there.
The content is my thumbnail that says that I won.
Don't fuck this up for me.
Get the fuck out of here.
You pre-made your...
You pre-made your thumbnail?
Yeah, I'm gonna have to pay for another thumbnail.
You gotta post that regardless.
I got money like that.
Come on.
Regardless of what happens, you gotta post that thumbnail.
I won, parentheses.
Kinda.
Almost.
I won, bracket baited.
On the thumbnail?
Like they didn't even click it yet?
Yeah, yeah, they didn't click.
Please click.
I won, I swear.
You couldn't... You wouldn't believe this, guys.
I won.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see how she plays.
Coach, you never told me like how to...
like what to do about SK.
You never told me anything.
Just grip her up.
Really?
Oh my god, you're right!
Just grip her up.
She's scared, bro.
Just grab.
Oh!
Oh my god, you're right!
Yup.
Wait!
Is this true?
Oh my goodness.
Oh, what?
Maybe not.
Never mind.
Oh, what?
Maybe not.
Never mind.
Now you can just punch.
Maybe not.
Let's go!
Oh my god, she's making it look real!
Oh wait, what the f- Oh, guys?
Guys?
Guys, she's not playing anymore.
She's like, Fuck it, I don't want this.
I hate that shit.
We were just fucking with you.
Oh my god, what a soul attack.
Oh my god.
We were just messing about.
Doki!
Wait!
Maybe she is making it look real!
She's making it look so real!
No!
The fix?
The fix is in?
Wait, is it true?
Bro, did you actually do it?
For us?
No, she's playing for real.
You got this.
Oh my goodness.
Are you sure?
I thought you were throwing to be honest.
Guys, I don't know what happened.
I don't know what to do when she does that.
Do that.
Holy shit.
Adlata.
She's so scared of you.
Why?
Because you're good!
You're fucking good!
Oh my.
Oh fuck.
Guys, guys.
Wait, do I hit that?
No way.
No fucking way!
Can I get a yay in the chat?
Yay!
What the fuck?
The ESAM Slayer is down!
Oh my god!
One more, one more, one more.
Let's get it.
It's okay, it's over.
We're done.
I'm the best in the tournament.
You're killing it.
One more, one more.
Just keep it up.
Keep it up.
Send that Chipotle code!
No ground taken.
Let's go.
It's time to send in that Chipotle code.
Thank you.
One more.
One more, one more.
I already got my one win.
I don't care anymore.
No, you care.
You care a lot.
Wait, what's in it for me?
A win?
I got a set!
We're gonna fucking win!
But I got a set though!
I tried to do that thing you did, but it didn't work.
Guys, I think she like...
You only told her to do one set, and she wasn't...
Oh yeah, didn't you say throw a set?
Damn it.
God damn it!
Pro!
You promised a whole set!
Oh, you're cooking.
Am I?
No fucking way!
Let's fucking go.
You're actually a better player!
Am I?
Yes, you are.
She's so scared, Doki.
Dude, Josh is in the living room.
He just said, let's go Doki.
Oh, yay!
Let's go Doki!
SK, please, the content would be so funny!
It really would!
It would be so good!
SK, just think about it!
Oh my god, the mid.
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
There's no way!
Oh, no!
Nooooooo!
Ah!
Goodbye.
She's dead, right?
Pro, yeah.
I'm dead.
No, I'm 100% dead.
Hey, you had that, Doki.
That was all you.
Oh, you're alive!
No, wait!
No!
There was nothing.
Close them, close them.
Fight!
Oh, hello.
Oh, she ducks now!
That's fine, that's fine.
It's a running me now.
Okay.
Goodbye.
How do you get up?
How are you getting up?
Goodbye.
Yes!
For one start.
Come on.
Yay!
Oh my, a Kolean hit.
No!
I forgot to do that mid thing.
It's cool, it's cool.
It's cool, you're cooking her.
Am I?
Yes, you are, yes.
You truly are.
The Doki!
Oh, that got her hit!
Finish her!
I got a point!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go Doki!
Unbelievable.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Let's go Doki!
We did it!
The Alley Kicks!
Oh my god!
Since I beat SK and SK beat Xezeb, I'm better than Ezeb!
It's actually true.
We call that the Armada number in Melee.
Yes!
We win these!
Holy shit.
That's actually insane.
That is actually...
I told you we don't need defense!
I can't believe it.
Do we have any defense?
No.
We don't.
No?
I'm active!
Yes yes.
Oh, yes!
The Damn Ice Freeze.
That's my goat.
Oh my god, he almost did a combo.
Nice dude.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Nice!
King sweet!
Nice.
Good shit.
That was good.
Oh my nesto.
What a duck, Kony.
Nice.
Don't hold forward after that.
No.
Oh shit.
She doesn't know.
That's a failure of these by the way.
What the fuck?
You didn't teach that on you buddy.
That's on you buddy.
We got three king players and you didn't teach them how to get up properly?
Nice.
Freaky king.
Freaky king!
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Yes!
Here we go.
Oh!
Good shit!
I tried to alley kick.
That was good.
Yeah.
Strong player.
This is truly finals.
Fight!
Got it bro.
Yeah she saw it.
Nice.
Good mid.
Okay.
Alright.
Lock in.
She's in my head.
Oh my god.
She's exactly.
Alright.
I gotta lock in.
She's kinda killing it now.
Okay.
That's why I'm making it close.
Making it close.
Good low.
She's gonna get up correctly now.
They're live coaching.
Yeah.
No.
You're right.
I'm live coaching.
Yeah.
So hit the alley kick after.
Oh my goodness.
He's dead.
That's counter hits.
Is he alive?
Nice.
Yes!
Go Coyne!
Go!
Nice.
What is that?
He lost bro!
That's Stone Cold!
That's Stone Cold?
It's cold like Sajan.
That's what Sajan is.
It's Slam Truth!
That's Stone Cold Steve Austin bro!
Looks like he has like a fucking pimple on his head.
The Looney Tunes injury.
The anvil.
Y'all don't know about Coyne's PM Wario dude.
Get ready for the next battle.
Oh PM Wario.
Yeah we got Wario here.
Yeah.
PM Wario bro.
Wah.
Okay.
Lock in brother.
Again!
She needs to do a crowd.
She got a death.
Wario!
Oh!
Okay she's waiting now.
Which means...
Love battle.
That's right.
That's what it takes brother.
Death by a mystery.
Give me your points!
Yes!
Sweep the team!
She's scared now.
Now we run up grab.
Oh my god.
She's so scared.
You're predicting her life!
Oh my fucking goodness.
Oh!
Counter hit everywhere.
Never let her get up!
Nice punish Cody!
That's a punish.
The one two.
That was a punish.
Now we fight.
Yeah!
Now we fight at the start.
I get it.
I know how this game works.
Now we fight.
He is unreal.
Who is he?
Starting to believe.
He moves like they do.
He's in her mind.
Good shit.
I hate this stage.
We just have to give her one you know.
Good mid.
Not these fuck... How many walls are in this fucking...
Holy shit!
It's like seven.
It's a temple.
It's okay.
Two of them are gone now.
So it's okay.
It's a bit bigger now.
Nice.
We're good.
It's fine.
Oh I pressed.
Okay.
It's fine.
Good adaptation.
Alright.
I know what to do.
I just stagger offense.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh!
What else my goat?
You still have smash though.
That's a wincon.
And she's burning rage.
He had a lot of gray life though.
So it's gonna take that.
But other than that you don't have to worry about it.
Okay.
Yeah.
One more mix.
She was in the air.
Oh!
What a block by her.
Oh my god!
I got an alley kick!
I got a down back three!
Nice try.
I gotta get off that stage.
I'm getting off there.
Very close.
It was close.
She's playing a lot bro.
She got better.
Fuck.
Yeah.
100%.
She's playing county king.
I just gotta grab more.
I know the timing.
Yeah.
She doesn't tech.
She's barely been ducking either.
No.
Yeah.
I got it.
You just wanted to be a pretty king for a third round.
I got a good stage here.
Let's get it.
Oh nice.
Okay.
Come on baby.
Is she scared at the start again?
That would be hilarious.
I could have just done the fucking pedigree again.
Drop his wallet.
That's okay.
Oh fuck man.
I didn't know it was that punishable.
No.
Nice dude.
That just locks me in.
It's okay.
Nice.
Nice hog kick bro.
Guaranteed at the wall.
Uh oh.
Wow.
What an alley kick.
Nice.
The fuck I'm talking about dude.
Three alley kicks.
Three kings.
Nice.
Good shit.
I tried to go low.
Wow.
That break.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Nice option.
She's anxious.
Nice.
Got up wrong.
More mix.
More grabs.
She got up way wrong.
You got up wrong dude.
Oh nice.
Nice.
Oh.
End it.
Come on Kony.
You got this Kony.
Muscle Buster breaks the floor.
Lil B is watching.
Oh we fucked it up.
It's okay.
Oh my goodness.
Dude.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
He's a bus ass.
Oh he's fucking a muscle busker.
Fucking.
Nice!
End it!
Great game!
Explode!
Nice!
Oh, fuck yeah, man.
Cody wins!
Cody let's go!
She got very good.
King sweep!
She was playing really good.
Her composure has gotten so much better, dude.
I like... I kind of steamrolled her at certain points, but like, there were other times that she took the game back from me.
Phew!
That's crazy.
PDX, because I'm going to lose to FD.
Dude, relax.
You've got this.
Slime's turn.
Slime, you've got this!
You could just end it right now.
I could end it right now.
Do you want live coaching slime?
I mean, just tell me right now.
Yes.
Let's try it in the first game.
I think I know what I have to do.
Like taunts while rage-guarding.
Here we go.
What a day, man.
I know, dude.
I'm going to drink after this.
I actually need to chill the brain.
Jesus.
Who needs defense?
I'm here to represent all the King players that don't block.
She's a real one.
Alright, brother.
Let's go.
Round one.
Fight.
Six.
Nice.
Stay composed, slime.
You can do these combos.
What the fuck?
Good shit!
This guy's free to running 1 plus 2.
He doesn't do anything at that range.
Oh, nice!
Bro, slime, I'm going to tell you the truth, dude.
I think he knows he has to win.
He's food.
He's fucking food!
He's food!
He's going to be missing in the forest later.
He's so scared.
He doesn't want to lose it.
Yeah, he wants to put the pressure on the other guy.
That's right, slime.
Yes, slime!
Oh, my God!
Eat him!
Eat the bird, too!
Eat the fucking bird!
I thought this guy was nice, bro.
What the fuck?
We let him get one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn, that's a lot, though.
That one is a lot.
Bro!
No, we ducked that one.
We ducked that, actually.
Oh, my God!
I think somebody really wants to win.
You have heat, slime.
Oh, big grab!
Dragon!
Dragon booty!
The fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
I can't believe he didn't attend it.
That's actually crazy.
He's desperate as fuck.
He's so desperate, slime.
Give us that lag coaching, bro!
He's gonna shoulder you every time you do back one.
You have to stop.
Unless you think he's gonna hit you.
Unless you think he's gonna pressure you, then you have to do it.
But he has the punish.
Jesus!
Yeah, back one as long as you don't think he's gonna block.
Nice.
Oh, that lag stack.
That's a wall combo.
Nice!
Oh my god.
Get off the ground!
Fish!
Mix!
Oh!
That's...
Rage art!
Aww.
That's gonna kill you.
Aww, it's so close.
In that situation, the hunting bear stance 1 plus 2 would have worked where you were in hunting and you could have just back off.
It would have worked.
And if you did your wall...
When I said wall combo, you did the wall combo there.
I mean, he was dead.
Yeah, I thought I couldn't because I blew my like...
I thought I blew something.
You did your heat burst, but that's fine.
Yeah, you can still do it.
And also, when you got a wall spike, you did G clef and then you tried to do the back 3 plus 4.
That's not gonna work because G clef counts as a tornado.
I'm using my tornado, yeah.
So if you G clef...
Yeah, it's just one set.
Then you can do down back 1 plus 2 spam.
Okay.
That will work after that as a wall combo.
You got this, dude.
You already know what to do.
Also, when you get mid range, he's free to wall running 1 plus 2.
Fight!
Where's Hopkick's at?
Yeah!
Ha!
Stop.
That's crazy, man.
I can't believe that's 3 steps.
That's crazy.
You got this, dude.
Yeah, only back 1 for the moves.
Nice!
Good shit!
Back 2-2-1!
And then do it again after the tornado.
That's fine too.
Yeah, whatever.
Right there.
Nice slime.
Nice!
You can back to one.
Up forward to Rayshard.
Nice!
Good shit!
Oh!
Nice.
Beautiful.
That's okay dude.
Just focus.
You got it.
I mean like... Good shit!
You are the bear player.
Nice slime!
We believe!
What the micro... I didn't mean to do that dude.
This lag sucks.
It's okay.
It's just so fucking laggy.
Yeah, team lag.
Team lag.
That's the joke of the game dude.
That's okay.
I'm about to fight FD on the microwave.
It's like why...
It's okay.
They just needed one.
They needed one.
It's okay.
MatPat is gonna fucking take it home.
For us.
Three straight would have been a little embarrassing for them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Save me 58 defense.
Save me.
Save me 58 defense Jack.
I will try dude.
Get his ass.
He's got three characters.
Well he's got two.
He's not gonna play Jack but... He's going Eddy brother.
Yeah.
I will try.
I don't know bro.
Just get ready to play Fee Fee Fee.
Shut up bro.
Win the tournament now.
Yeah.
We got this.
This guy plays on a DS.
I swear to god.
I feel the fringe.
This guy is playing Eddy bro.
Pray to Jack Jesus right now.
Chat.
Get the prayers going in.
Uh oh.
You just have to be offensive until you think he's gonna power crash.
Then you have to launch that.
Offend him.
Round one.
Fight.
Infinite.
He hasn't learned.
Oh.
He doesn't know how to get up there.
I would have taught him.
I would have taught him bro.
If he was on the squad.
He's so freaky.
I don't know what character he does dude.
I'm literally just playing out feel.
Got it.
All good.
It's only one.
Wow.
Beautiful.
Fight.
That's a third hit.
Yeah.
Nice.
He's got guns in his hands.
It's fine.
It's still alive.
I know that's fucking launch.
What a block man.
Good fucking block.
What a read.
Come on baby.
Oh.
Oh fuck.
I wanted to dump for two.
It's okay.
You got the set.
Fight.
It's over.
That's launch.
Scarecrow three.
Great job.
That's launch.
He's dead.
Maybe.
Uh oh.
They're doing wall carry.
Why did I get the god wall?
I don't know.
Thank you.
No.
Oh my god.
Wall to wall?
God wanted us to win.
God's first son.
God's favorite player.
He gave it to you.
Jack got mad freaky.
Happy Sunday everybody.
It is his day.
I can't believe he got it.
I was thinking about that wall.
I was thinking about it.
And dude.
I was like okay.
Maybe he's gonna stay on the ground.
Cause this is gonna whiff.
I gotta plant the seed.
It's not just clean splat.
That's crazy.
Get ready for the next battle.
Phew.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh my god.
He doesn't know that.
Eddie.
Boom.
One.
4-1-1.
He won.
1-1.
That's my goat.
Come on Eddie.
You have to use other numbers.
Fight.
Oh.
Get the fuck out of here.
Kick man.
That dodge though in the beginning.
Where's the dizzy meter?
I know his ass is dizzy as hell.
He's nauseous.
No way.
He's gonna kick.
Oh my god.
That's clean.
Nice punish.
Oh my god.
That was a nice punish.
Send the rocket.
Drop the fucking got him.
Drop the fucking.
I fucking got him.
The cross from space.
Pray chat.
Pray.
I swear to god it lagged.
It's cool bro.
We bouncing here.
Oh my god.
Your feet.
It was fate.
We had to end the tournament this way.
Put him away Jack.
Come on Jack.
Oh my god.
No.
It's fine bro.
We believe in you.
Oh shit.
Come on.
It's Sunday.
This is your day.
Oh that's a punish.
But he's not dead.
Oh it's counter hit though.
No way the tournament ends here.
That'd be insane.
Alright chat.
Oh my goodness.
That's it.
It's an end.
Oh.
Jesus.
Jack Jesus.
My savior.
My ass.
This is a new fucking game.
Uninstall now.
Holy shit man.
Oh my god.
Many blessings.
Fuck yeah.
Many blessings upon all chats.
He is risen once more.
Oh my god.
Oh my dude.
We got first.
We fucking did it.
We fucking did it man.
The Doki Diff.
Oh my god.
I clutched it when it matters.
I can't believe that.
I can't believe it.
Ball pool did not have to play.
It's just like the first slam all over again.
You can rest.
He can rest.
That's asking for an exhibition.
I'm about to say no.
That's the profit bro.
Come on.
Do an exhibition.
Let's do take a ball.
Take a ball.
Do it.
It's worth nothing.
Your team already won.
I want to see you play.
I want to see you play again for the road.
For the homies.
Do it for the family.
No pressure.
Nothing.
Just let's get it.
It's the after party bro.
They want to ban King.
I'm just going on.
Three Kings win it.
True.
Well, well, well.
What up team Brawl Pro?
Hi.
Hey.
What's good?
Can I just say congratulations to Doki for winning a tripping game?
Let's fucking go.
True.
I have a 30 on defense.
Wait.
You actually clutched up big time against us.
You did.
You really fucking did dude.
That was on.
How many.
I feel like you've been putting in the night shift.
Is that the case?
Like Doki is the late night Tekken grinder.
Yeah.
I'm the late night Tekken grinder.
I only play Tekken at night.
I look.
It's like 2 AM and you're like yo BP you up?
Like yo what's good?
And then he's just like I'll get out of bed.
Like I'll pull up.
What's good?
So I'm very impressed.
But I was going to say congrats to all of your team.
You all played very, very well.
I'm impressed with your performance.
First time that we didn't see Brawl Pro have to clutch it up too.
I know.
No, that's wrong actually.
Cause I had to against Tony.
Remember?
Oh, I know.
That's what I'm saying.
You didn't have to play that game.
It's the first time you did.
He had to win so many high pressure sets dude.
He had to get us to the finals.
But then we finish it off for him.
Memories of Slam 1.
Yeah.
I was going to say.
I was going to ask for all of you.
How is his coaching style?
What do you like about being on Brawl Pro's team?
Dude, I say what is this?
And then he doesn't fucking answer me.
I don't know why he does that to Matt only.
That's kind of weird.
I swear to God.
Is that personal?
That guy knows how to play Slam 2.
I'll just leave him alone.
He leaves me alone.
He thinks I'll figure it out myself.
I don't understand.
But you know what?
He was right.
He must be goaded.
You're the oldest child.
You don't need as much help as us.
Yeah, that's true.
He just gives you your own designs.
You're the oldest.
You have to take care of us.
You need more help man.
I was going to say also.
You look like you locked in Matt.
You played really well.
Today especially I feel like you were pretty solid looking in every single set that I saw you play.
I played Tekken until 7am last minute because I was like there's no way I'm fucking losing.
We covered like Alyssa and stuff but not Zaf I don't think.
I encountered a Zafina, a supreme Zafina who I was just doing like a ranked grind.
Like I kept kewing into her at 7am like constantly.
And that was my practice.
I got lucky.
I was also going to say.
So Dokia are you coming to EVO?
Maybe.
I'm just checking.
I really appreciate you playing in the tournament regardless.
It's very nice of you to do so.
If you want to come.
You know let me know.
I'd appreciate it.
They are asking for a coach match if you guys want to play.
Do it do it do it bro.
I was going to say.
EVO offered to fly the first place team out.
If you guys want.
And you're cool with it and EVO doesn't mind.
If you want to pass your trip down.
To second place.
And you guys want to pass third place instead.
Well I don't know.
We got to think about it.
You know what I mean.
We're talking about a per diem lobster dinner.
Yeah I think we get a per diem instead.
What about our budget?
Our EVO budget.
Okay let me just.
Tony they said.
They said go fuck yourself.
I can still go right?
It would have been down to 1 until Tony said.
Yeah.
No the orphans.
No not them either.
The orphans can't come.
Yeah sorry so I got off the phone with Tony.
Seems understandable.
I'm down with that.
I guess I lost it for all of us guys.
None of us are going to EVO.
Sorry guys.
So you know.
Thanks to all of you for playing by the way.
I really really appreciate it.
Thanks for having us man.
Yeah I'd love to do another.
If you ever do another Sajab Slam.
I'd love to join again.
It's been so fun.
Good luck in your coaches match.
Why the fuck are you on Kuma?
Wait he's playing Kuma?
Why the hell is this dude on Kuma?
Because Kuma is the GOAT.
Uh oh big ass bear watch out.
Oh my god.
I played Fii with King twice already.
In both round robins.
He wouldn't expect.
Oh!
Broken plate.
A cat and a bear.
This is no joke.
Jesus Christ that sounded like it hurt.
Yeah you heard that shit?
Like a gunshot bite to the ground man.
Uh oh.
Hit him with a cool move coach.
Do a cool move.
Yeah do a cool move.
Coach get up.
Do it come on.
Do the move.
Maybe we should have gone kick coach.
Coach where is the king?
Go Paul.
Go Paul please.
Oh go Paul.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
I haven't played Paul in like two months.
I don't care bro kick his ass.
Yeah kick his ass.
He's only Tekken God Supreme.
Let's do a cool move coach.
What the?
Oh dude the alley kicks up before Kuma.
Oh that's good.
Yeah.
That's a fast move.
Fight.
No wait we go.
Okay.
Hook our ass.
One moves.
He does.
What the fuck.
Coach come on.
Oh that's kind of pretty I like that.
Got it.
Oh nice.
Setting missile.
You think that thing tastes good?
Bro roast that.
Watch this mix.
Maybe I'm just hungry.
We've been playing Tekken for six hours.
Actually I'm fucking starving.
What the fuck.
Fight.
Respectfully coach I'm gonna need you to lock in.
Yeah coach.
There we go yeah.
Yeah.
That move is silly.
Such good wall running inputs.
He does it on a lever too.
How does he do it?
Let's see Paul Allen's lever.
Uh oh.
Oh no way they gave him that one.
That wall is hunking me pretty hard.
It's the fee difference.
Back to one perfectly planned.
Are you kidding me?
Oh no.
Hit her one time coach.
Come on coach just put it in.
No.
Well actually this isn't even your main so you have to go.
Yeah yeah that's fine.
You almost beat her.
You almost beat them.
Exactly.
That's just embarrassing for them.
He tried so hard.
That shit was so close on Kuma.
I wanna stay bear.
Stay bear?
Come on.
You have to play until we get another set.
You gotta play king so we can get another set.
There's nothing wrong with bear.
You can play the bear.
Come on.
I do support bear to be fair.
I'll support bear.
What about Paul?
You're asking for Paul but I would.
I just haven't played him in like two months.
Make them play a different character.
He's so scared.
You are scared to play Paul.
Yeah.
And that's...
dare I say pathetic.
That's a moral failing.
No I wanna play king.
He's fine.
There you go.
True.
We blocked that.
Nice.
What's the cool combo?
Do the really cool showcase combo.
It's kinda boring coach.
Let's do a cool thing.
Oh that was a cool step.
Beautiful.
Okay.
Did he bounce?
What did we do?
We did something cool.
Fuck optimization.
That was optimal.
That was fucking...
I'm saying you...
Fuck optimization.
Show me some cool shit.
Yeah show me all the cool combos.
That can never do.
Oh wow.
Time out?
Woah woah.
This is chess.
Oh.
Let's go.
Yes!
3% 3% dip.
Bro do the wall jump again.
That was so cool.
That was not happening again.
Do the wall jump bro.
Do the wall jump coach.
Hit the spider man.
Uh oh.
No way he does it 3 times right?
She's mad easy.
Can you giant swing PDX 3 times?
Yeah yeah can you do that?
In a row.
Like don't do anything else but giant swing.
Yeah yeah.
Now do it again.
I don't think he's gonna live.
Poor PDX bro.
Bro he's trying his hardest out right now.
Lily isn't gonna be able to talk after this.
Her brain is just pasting to her skull.
Round 3.
Fight.
Bro is being audio terrorized.
Oh he took damage.
Okay.
Oh nice.
Alright I see coach we condition 2 to then do 1.
True.
Oh wow.
Bro Fee might be the GOAT.
I might have a new coach next slim.
Wait.
He's kinda not.
I wonder if he can teach me.
Lily!
Bro bro you really got led coach Cody?
What are you aiming at?
Oh!
Oh this is it.
Tony you made him mad.
You made our coach mad.
Look at him.
Now he's taking it out on her.
Not mad coach you're the only one for me.
Oh staying up with the spring kick?
Are you crazy?
I don't know why that worked.
Right garage coach.
Death Cater.
Okay how long is this?
That's the last.
Actually go for RDC I'm not kidding.
Do the RDC.
They would never expect it.
Show me something cool coach.
You made me remove my RDC binds.
Or K-Pitch.
RDC binds?
Yeah I had RDC binds.
He made me remove it.
Cause I kept accident.
He wants it.
I can see it.
I see him fishing.
He wants it so bad.
How do we lock it in?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Wow!
Let him go!
Oh that's a lot of kicks.
Lock in brother.
Ouch.
Oh.
That plays king.
That is how true champion fights.
For the one time hit the RDC though.
Yeah yeah yeah.
His ass will break it.
Come on.
It's got the new hole too.
You think he knows that?
Yeah but he won it for the content.
But what if he's trying to break something else?
Cause he's like there's no way he can RDC.
If he gets rolling death cradle, FDX will never live that down.
Even for content.
There's no way he's not pressing 2.
He's taking kicked off this guys.
Like he's gonna get his drop sponsor.
They're gonna call him out.
It's in his contract.
He's like never get RDC'd.
You had to press 2 dude.
He's hit 2 once bro.
Fire!
That war.
Can't stop me.
All right.
Painting sausage I do.
I'm not New York City.
He's a.
Smart.
There's a fucking cheater in town square.
This bloody cheater is harassing me.
Where's the bobbies?
Just can't put a chicken pie in the pub.
Where's the bobbies in this lot?
This bloke just poked me in my toes.
I'll have the fucking chips after this.
I will.
Oh, she's playing it!
Oh, that cheeky cat!
That cheeky cat!
Help me!
Oh, bloody hell!
Me back!
Why are you mashing, Fi?
What are you doing?
That's meaty!
RDC!
At least go for it, coach!
Come on, go for it!
Keep him honest.
You gotta keep him honest about it.
Oh, he wants... I see it!
Yeah, he sees it.
He's like...
Okay!
Two!
He's like, no!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
He knows.
Hey, you tried!
You tried!
We take those!
I mean, you got the image out of that.
You're welcome.
Oh!
With the bare feet, dude?
Should have let him RDC'd, bro!
Oh, we dodged that!
Round three.
Oh my god, dude.
Fight!
Bro, he should have let you RDC'd.
I would have let it happen.
Yeah!
Finish it all!
It's okay, you don't need that Chipotle sponsor.
That is absurd!
Chip, dude.
That is crazy!
Oh my god!
Yeah, that's crazy.
Jesus, dude.
Round four.
One, two, three.
At least Ali could kick to the end.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was... What move was that?
How come he knew that, but he didn't teach the players?
Yeah!
He didn't teach nobody that.
He's saving it for Nationals.
Well, he just did a jump in like he's Ryu.
That was literally an anime fighter.
What the fuck?
What the fu- Oh my god!
Ali kick!
He's dead.
Goodbye!
Sayonara!
I'm in the cop car!
Take him away, boys!
Well done.
We dominated, everyone.
We win.
We're the best.
We're the ghosts.
Best team.
Best vibes.
Best fan art.
Best fans.
Best team.
Best fan art.
Best fans.
We actually did it, guys.
We didn't have to go to the coach's match for the tiebreaker.
Tech kid ball.
World Finals.
Woo!
Good shit, guys.
GG's, everybody.
We fucking did it, man!
We fucking did it!
We got first place!
I love you guys, dude!
Seriously!
Unbelievable, man.
I want the ghost of Super to come, like, Anakin's dad.
I'm gonna go on Super Chat and be like, guess what?
We got first.
Unbelievable, man.
Good shit, guys.
Straight up.
Wow.
Oh my god.
We got little Sayjam controllers again.
Yeah!
We got the first place ones this time.
Yeah, look at that.
True, bro!
We got two controllers!
Wait!
Oh my god.
My chat is saying, all five of you raid Super.
No.
That would be really funny.
Hey, Lil Bro, where were you?
Why were...
I... Weren't you training SK earlier?
Oh, true.
Oh my god.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
First fucking place.
Team Brawl Pro continues to be on top, no matter what.
No one expected us to take it to the first.
But here we are.
Dude, Tony's team, because they beat us 4-1, right?
Yeah.
It was bad.
It was brutal.
But you guys put in so much freaking work, man.
Yeah, we literally put them on tilt, too.
Yeah!
We put them on tilt so we get the free PDX win.
No offense, but let's be honest.
Let's be honest.
That shit was kind of easy.
No, well, I mean, look.
Feng Wei...
No, no.
Your seed is fucked.
Honestly, like, I don't blame you.
Dude, yeah.
You had Roy, you had that Feng player.
You had your roommate, your best friend, whatever.
That shit was fucked up, dude.
Yeah, the third seed was literally fucked up.
Like, it was insane.
Not a you issue, genuinely.
We did it, bro.
Well, I...
Yeah, I'm actually gonna... Well, they said that you can stay in the Discord and we're gonna hang out, so...
I would stay in the Discord.
Yeah, you know how...
late night in the Discord, people are hanging out and playing better?
Oh, really?
Yeah, come check out the Discord, because we literally just sit and we just talk.
Like, everyone comes in.
Oh, that sounds neat.
I'll probably pop in.
I'm hungry, bro.
Yeah, I got it.
I'm gonna fucking smoke a doobie and then get some Jack in the Box.
Good fucking night.
You earned it, bro.
You earned it.
That's an American reset.
I'm actually...
I'm literally American resetting my brain right now.
You earned it, man.
Six hours of Tekken.
You deserve it, man.
You all...
You're all fucking amazing, GG.
I could not ask for a better team.
Once again.
Unbelievable.
GG's, everybody.
Have a great time.
I'm so happy to be part of the team.
I'll see you guys at EVO, man!
Yeah!
Let's get fucking food!
Good shit, guys.
Good shit.
See you guys.
We gotta... Oh, god.
I'm sad it's over.
Over the school year.
Stay in touch.
It's so sad, man!
Alright, alright.
Next stage at Slam, guys.
Street Fighter.
We all get together again.
I'm in there.
I'll med train that shit.
For sure.
Same.
Same, dude.
Alright, I'll see you later, guys.
Alright, bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
See you at Slam.
Oh, my god!
I... Honestly, I did not expect to win against SK because SK won against ESAM and then I did not know what the fuck ESAM was...
I was doing with ESAM.
So, I was so surprised.
I can't believe I won against SK.
I told...
Guys, I told you.
All I needed to do was just not think.
The moment I stopped thinking, like, it works.
It just works.
My brain...
I don't know what... I don't know what I'm doing.
She doesn't know what I'm doing.
So, she's confused.
And I'm confused.
And then I won!
Oh, my god!
I can't believe it!
We clutched it!
That's the one that matters!
We might have lost the other games today, but we won the finals match.
Which matters the most, because that meant Brawl Pro didn't have to do the final coaching fight.
Once I relaxed, I started... I started fucking.
Oh, my god!
I'm so happy!
I'm so, so, so happy, guys!
I'm really happy with this team.
It was... it was such a great team.
Brawl Pro was actually... despite how much we roast Brawl Pro, it was a great coach.
He taught me those six moves.
The six most important moves ever to get me here.
If it weren't for those six moves and that alley kick, I would not have been here.
Thank you, guys, for cheering us on!
I'll miss this team, honestly.
This was such a great team.
I love this team so much.
I couldn't have asked for a better group of people to vibe with.
Honestly, thank you guys for cheering us on.
What a fucking arc for me.
Fighting game arc we had there.
The fact that we went from zero fighting game experience with only like 50 hours played.
Started off... started training late.
Later than all the others.
Gamers that were on.
All the other gamers that were in my seed.
I trained...
I started training a week late.
Because I was so busy.
So...
And then had the... and then had the fucked up PC until I fixed it the last day.
My PC was so fucked until I fixed it today for just this tournament.
And we managed to...
clutch it.
I'm so happy.
I'm really, really happy.
But yes!
Thank you everybody.
I'm gonna rest now.
Haven't had dinner yet.
And we trained for six hours.
And we grind... we played Tekken for six hours.
And I trained yesterday for so long too.
I mean I got... I ranked up last night.
Cause I was just training and rank.
And I'm just so happy it's over.
Thank you everybody for watching!
As always everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you did that for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!